mes chers
collègues mesdames messieurs nous nous
retrouvons ce matin pour une table ronde
sur le lien entre les trajectoires des
finances publiques et la croissance
économique dans les différents pays
européens avec un regard évidemment
centré sur la France je signale d'emblé
que s'il est impossible d'ignorer le
sujet de la révision des règles
budgétaire européenne cette table ronde
n' pas vocation à s'y réduire l'ambition
de cette de table ronde est d'ailleurs
tout d'abord de lever le voile sur ce
qui paraît constituer une spécificité
française en terme de finances publiqu
de mieux appréhender la situation des
autres pays européens et de revenir sur
les raisons des divergences qui peuvent
exister alors même que la grande
promesse de l'euro était la convergence
des économies
européennes dans une visée autant
théorique qu'empirique je demanderaai
également à nos invités d'aborder le
lien entre trajectoire des finances
publiques et croissance économique si
l'impact positif de la croissance sur le
budget ne fait pas vraiment de doute à
court terme celui des finances publiques
sur la croissance est beaucoup plus
débattu au moins deux économistes car
Carmen Reinard et kenf rogof avaient cru
pouvoir dégager en 2010 ça date un peu
un seuil de 90 % à partir duquel la
dette publique venait affaiblir la
croissance mais ce résultat a été très
contesté si des effets de seuil semblent
pouvoir exister ils sont probablement
propre à chaque pays par ailleurs la
question de la trajectoire de la dette
publique paraît au moins aussi
importante voire plus que celle du seuil
elle ne peut pas non plus être séparée
de la finalité de l'endettement si
celui-ci permet d'investir dans la
transition écologique l'éducation les
infrastructures ou la recherche il sera
plus soutenable que s'il vise simplement
à satisfaire quelques intérêts
catégori enfin même si un haut niveau de
dette publique peut poser problème
certains économies estime qu'une
consolidation trop rapide peut être pire
encore qu'en est-il aujourd'hui alors
que l'économie semble être revenue dans
la phase huteute du cycle ces questions
se posent au niveau national au niveau
de la zone euro dans son ensemble mais
également entre pays quel impact une
consolidation budgétaire en Allemagne ou
une relance en Italie peuvent-elles
avoir sur l'économie française et plus
généralement de la situation économique
et des finances publiques d'un état sur
celle des autres États-membres en
filigran apparaît la question de la
coordination économique et budgétaire
entre les États-membres trop souvent
réduite à celle cert essentielle de la
maîtrise des dépenses publiques dans ce
contexte il paraît inévitable de revenir
sur les règles budgétaires européennes
dont la révision est en cours après
qu'un accord soit intervenu le 20
décembre dernier entre les différents
pays européens sont-ell bien calibré
permettent-elles d'assignir les finances
publiques des différents pays sans porté
excessivement atteinte à leur croissance
encourage-elle suffisamment
l'investissement dans les secteurs clés
bon vous le voyez mais vous le savez
l'éventail des questions est
inépuisable alors pour nous éclairer sur
ces enjeux nous avons donc le plaisir
d'accueillir monsieur Luc tolonia
directeur en charge de l'économie des
États-membres à la Direction Générale
des Affaires économiques et financières
de la Commission européenne Monsieur
François ECAL que nous recevons
régulièrement président de l'association
fipeco et conseiller honoraire à la Cour
des comptes Monsieur Jérôme CREL
directeur du département des études de
l'Observatoire français des conjonctures
économiques l'OFCE est spécialiste des
questions
européenne je vous rappelle à vous trois
que cette audition fait l'objet d'une
captation vidéo retransmise en direct
sur le site du Sénat et donc sans plus
tarder je cède la parole à Monsieur Luc
tlonia pour qu'il nous présente la
situation des finances publiques des
différents pays européens comment
expliquez-vous donc les divergences à
l'œuvre estimez-vous qu'il existe une
spécificité française en matière de
finances publiqu peut-être
reviendrez-vous également sur la
révision des règles budgétaires
européennes alors vous le savez ce type
d'audition est un peu piégeux parce que
on vous demande beaucoup de choses et de
le faire dans un temps limité euh ça
fait partie de sachant qu'ensuite vous
aurez évidemment des questions qui vous
ramèneront et qui vous permettront de
compléter éventuellement vos positions
donc une première introduction monsieur
tolonia Monsieur le Directeur merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs chers collègues
bonjour à tous dans mon introduction je
voudrais couvrir deux points ayant tras
au contexte européen tout d'abord
rappeler quelques faits marquants et
puis évoquer le cadre budgétaire
économique européen en cours
de négociation au niveau européen pour
cela j'ai préparé une série de
transparents qui ont été été circulé et
que je vais
utiliser tout
d'abord notre monnaie commune l'euro
faite ces 25 ans et et ce graphique vous
rappelle les grandes trajectoires de
croissance des principaux états- membres
au cours de ces 25 dernières années
euh nous exprimons ici la croissance en
terme de PIB réel par habitant euh les
performances varient selon les pays et
fil du temps mais des tendances communes
se dégagent compte tenu de l'intégration
de nos
économies on voit notamment l'impact des
deux pires crises économiques que
l'Union européenne na jamais connu
depuis la Seconde Guerre mondiale la
crise financière mondiale à partir de
2008 aggravé par la crise des dettes
souveraines en en zone euro puis celle
de la pandémie de covid en en 2020 en ce
début 2024 la situation économique
demeure incertaine dans un contexte
mondial fragilisé la croissance sera
certainement modeste à court terme ce
graphique inclut des prévisions qui date
de novembre dernier la Commission
européenne mettra à jour ses prévisions
le 15 février
prochain sur cette même période les
ratios de dettes publiques ont augmenté
de façon significative notamment lors
des épisodes récessif que je viens de
mentionner le ratio moyen de la zone
euro est passé de 60 % en 2000 à près de
100 % au pire de la crise
covid en 2020 depuis lors les ratios de
de dette ont tendance à baisser cela
reflète la vigueur de la reprise
économique postcovid mais aussi dans une
certaine mesure l'impact positif de
l'inflation sur le PIB en valeur qui
contribue à réduire le ratio de dette il
s'agit donc des faits de relatif court
terme qui ne préjuge pas des évolutions
de de plus long
terme le ratio moyen de dett publique de
la zone euro est repassé sous la barre
des 90 % au 3e trimestre
2023 sur les 20 pays de la zone euro six
pays conservent des ratios de dett
allant au-delà de 100 % du PIB dont la
France les CIN autres pays sont la Grèce
l'Italie l'Espagne la Belgique et le
Portugal le ratio de dette moyen de la
zone euro reste au-delà de ce qu'il
était avant la crise de la
covid en lien avec ce niveau de dette on
peut souligner deux autres faits
concernant la France en comparaison
d'autres pays euh nous voyons ici
l'évolution des déficits publics sur les
25 dernières années en ce qui concerne
la France euh le déficit public est
resté comparativement élevé sur la
période y compris lors de phases
économiques plus favorabl de fait sur
les 20 dernières années le déficit
annuel de la France n'est passé sous la
barre des 3 % qu'au cours de trois
exercices euh 2006 2007 et 2018
autre
fait saillant le fait que la France est
l'État membre de l'Union européenne avec
le taux de dépenses publiqu dans le PIB
le plus élevé cela est le cas depuis
maintenant près de 10 ans et vous voyez
sur ce graphique les dernières données
disponibles datant de 2022 la moyenne
européenne étant autour de 50
%. comme vous le savez les performances
économiques et budgétaires de la France
font l'objet d'un suivi régulier au
niveau européen dans le cadre de ce
qu'on appelle le semestre européen de
coordination des politiques économiques
en juillet dernier le Conseil de l'Union
européenne a émis ses recommandations
annuelles à la France elle soulligne le
besoin de poursuivre une stratégie
d'assaainissement budgétaire à moyen
terme combiné à des investissements et à
des réformes propisses à une croissance
durable plus forte voilà pour un bilan
rapide des trajectoires récentes au sein
de la zone euro alors quelle
perspectiv j'ai mentionné les prévisions
à horizon de 2 ans que la Commission
européenne publie régulièrement je
voudrais ici signaler la publication
d'un rapport important le rapport 2024
sur le
vieillissement qui est publié tous les 3
ans en en travail conjoint entre les
experts des États-membres et de la
Commission européenne afin d'établir des
projections à moyen et long terme en
matière démographique en matière de
croissance et en matière de finances
publiqu ce rapport est en fait composé
de deux parties une première partie qui
a été publié en novembre dernier qui a
trait aux hypothèses de démographique de
croissance et de
productivité et une deuxième partie sera
présentée en avril prochain au printemps
ayant trait aux finances publiques le
message principal de la première partie
de ce rapport est que en raison du
déclin démographique l'essentiel de la
croissance à l'avenir devra être tiré
par les gains de
productivité ces travails analytiques
de longue haline est un travail
important en vue de l'évolution des
règles possibles au niveau européen cela
m'amène à mon deuxième point évoquer
l'évolution du cadre économique européen
en cours de discussion au niveau
européen je ne vais pas rentrer dans le
détail de ces règles parce qu'elles sont
encore en cours de discussion monsieur
le Président vous avez rappelé qu'un
accord a été trouvé entre États-membres
de l'Union européenne lors du Conseil
Ecofin du 20 décembre dernier le parle
le Parlement européen en tant que
cégislateur a voté sur son rapport la
semaine dernière les trilogues ont
débuté le même jour mercredi dernier et
se poursuivront au cours des prochaines
semaines compte tenu des échéances
électorales il serait important que ces
trilogues aboutissent rapidement afin
que le Parlement européen actuel puisse
voter sous sa
mandature l'ambition est donc de de
pouvoir progresser au cours des
prochaines semaines euh des détails
importants restent à préciser euh je je
me contenterai ici de rappeler la
logique sous-jacente à cette révision et
à évoquer quelques possibles éléments
novateurs pourquoi de nouvelles règles
essentiellement pour trois séries de
raisons premièrement parce que
l'expérience acquise au cours des 25
dernières années a souligné plusieurs
défis de mise en œuvre le fait que les
niveaux detes soient restés globalement
élevés le fait que les situations
nationales demeurent relativement
htérogène le fait que les règles aent pu
rester complexes euh à plusieurs
reprises et euh le fait que
l'appropriation nationale de ces règles
a pu être
sous-optimale ces aspects ont été bien
documentés lors d'une vaste consultation
publique lancé en
2020 deuxème série de raisons de
nouveaux défis de nouveaux enjeux qui
s'intensif s'intensifieront à l'avenir
j'ai évoqué le vieillissement avec un
coût direct sur le financement de la
protection sociale mais aussi son impact
économique sur le potentiel de
croissance les besoins d'investissement
euh très signif significatif pour
faciliter la transition verte numérique
les enjeés de sécurité et défense et et
au-delà et aussi à plus court terme la
question du coût de financement de la
dette en raison de la remontée des taux
d'intérêt dans un contexte de de forte
inflation trème série de raison le
besoin de tenir compte des
développements suitees à la crise de la
covid et notamment de deux
développements majeurs en particulier
tout d'abord le fait que pour la
première fois depuis l'histoire du PACT
de stabilité et de croissance la clause
dérogatoire généralisé est été activée
en 2020 en réponse à la crise de la
covid cela a conduit à une suspension
des ajustement budgétaire requis et à
une flexibilité budgétaire sans
précédent cette clause a été prolongée
jusqu'en 2023 en raison de l'impacte de
la guerre en
Ukraine deuxième développement en
complément de cette flexibilité
budgétaire sans précédent le fait que
l'Union européenne s'est mis d'accord
sur un plan de relance lui aussi sans
précédent connu sous le nom de Next
Generation eu ce plan s'élève à 750
milliards d'euros soit près de 5 % du
PIB européen euh ce plan est venu
s'ajouter au 1000 milliards d'euros
prévu au titre de la politique de
cohésion pour la période de
programmation
2021-2027 le plan inclut la la facilité
pour la reprise et la résilience qui
bénéficie la France pour plus de 40
milliards d'euros afin d'accélérer la
transition verte et numérique pour
toutes ces raisons la consultation
publique de 2020 a été prolongée
jusqu'en 2022 la Commission européenne
alors fait part de ces grandes
orientations puis de ses propositions
législatives en avril 2023 avant que le
Parlement européen et le Conseil ne
formalisent leur position de négociation
au cours des dernières
semaines je le disais des éléments
importants restent donc à confirmer de
même que les dates d'entrée en vigueur
de de ces nouvelles règles mais l'esprit
général son semble converger je voudrais
ici mentionner cinq éléments plus
novateur qui pourrait ressortir de ces
discussions et qui concerne
essentiellement le volet préventif du
parc de stabilité croissance tout
d'abord la pluré annualité le fait que
les nouvelles règles seraient basées sur
des plans nationaux budgétaires et
structurels de plus long terme avec un
horizon de 4 ou 5 ans selon la durée de
la législature nationale ces plans
seraient proposés par les États-membres
et devrait faire l'objet d'une vaste
discussion pour favoriser leur
appropriation au niveau national deuxème
élément euh la définition d'une
trajectoire budgétaire qui soit
spécifique à chaque pays et différent
selon les risques en terme de
soutenabilité des finances publiques qui
leur sont propres là encore ce serait un
développement majeur la responsabilité
de proposer une trajectoire budgétaire
reviendrait en premier lieu aux
États-membres afin de guider cette
discussion la commission fournirait une
trajectoire technique basée sur une
méthodologie dite d'analyse de
soutenabilité de la dette pour la
première campagne de plan cette
méthodologie serait celle du cadre
d'analyse existant de la commission qui
est
largement disponible et qui a déjà fait
ses preuves troisème élément novateur la
possibilité de tenir compte des efforts
de réforme et d'investissement afin de
prolonger la période d'ajustement la
trajectoire budgétaire pourrait ainsi
être prolongée de 3 ans c'est-à-dire
passer de 4 à 7 ans et l'effort
d'ajustement annuel réduit en
conséquence afin de tenir compte de
réformes et d'investissement en lien
avec les priorités européenes là aussi
ces mesures seraient proposées par les
États-membres lors de la présentation de
leur plan quatrièmement afin d'assurer
une mise en d'œuvre crédible un certain
nombre de clauses de sauvegarde serait
précisé pour s'assurer que les niveaux
de de dette et de déficit diminue
suffisamment de même des clauses
dérocatoires seraient confirmées afin de
pouvoir tenir compte de situations
exceptionnelles affectant un État membre
ou affectant l'Union européenne dans son
ensemble dernièrement le suivi de la
mise en œuvre se ferait au moyen d'un
indicateur unique celui de la croissance
des dépenses nettes chaque indicateur a
ses forces et s faiblesses celui dit des
dépenses nettes a l'avantage d'exprimer
l'évolution des dépenses publiques
directement sous le contrôle des
gouvernements il exclut les intérêts de
la dette qui fluctuent en fonction des
conditions de marché de même qu'il
exclut des dépenses cycliques
d'assurance chômage qui fluctue en
fonction de la conjoncture c'est donc un
indicateur utile et robuste pour assurer
un suivi au fil du temps encore une fois
ces éléments restent à confirmer et à
préciser j'imagine que nous y
reviendrons dans la discussion je vous
remercie
merci Monsieur le Directeur je m'adresse
maintenant donc à
françoiscal nous connaissons bien je
l'ai indiqué vous publiez donc des notes
sur les finances publiques de manière
très
régulière y compris sur celle des pays
d'ailleurs de la zone euro et votre
dernier commentaire d'actualité
d'ailleurs intervient opportunément
puisqu'il porte justement sur les
nouvelles règles budgétaires européennes
donc je vous donne tout de suite la
parole
merci monsieur le Président merci
mesdames et Messieurs les sénateur de
m'avoir invité
aujourd'hui dans le temps limité de
cette introduction je vais surtout
parler de ce que je connais le mieux
finalement c'est-à-dire les les finances
publiques de la France parlons un petit
peu quand même aussi de l'Europe et de
la croissance alors quand je regarde
l'évolution du déficit public de la
France en pourcentage du PIB depuis le
début de la 5e République je constate
que d'abord dans les années 60 c'était
un excédent pas un déficit et puis
ensuite qu'on a eu un déficit qui s'est
aggravé à chaque fois que il y a une
crise ou un ralentissement de l'activité
économique puis ensuite bah il a diminué
quand ça allait mieux et puis il est
reparti à la hausse à la crise suivante
ou au ralentissement suivante et au
total sur l'ensemble de ces années on
est sur une tendance clairement
croissante le déficit public en
pourcentage du PIB augmente et si le
déficit public en pourcentage du PIB
augmente continuement la dette publique
en pourcentage du PIB augmente
continuement elle aussi et ceci est
totalement indépendant des taux
d'intérêt sujet que les économistes
aiment bien les taux d'intérêt peuvent
avoir n'importe quel niveau si vous avez
un déficit publi qui augmente
continuement la dette publique augmente
et donc c'est bien ce qu'on voit en
France puisqu'on voit bien que la dette
publique elle est elle était encore à 20
% du PIB au début des des années 80 et
ben comme le déficit à chaque fois qu'il
y a une crise ou un ralentissement elle
monte une marche d'escalier et puis
ensuite quand ça va mieux ben on arrive
tout juste à la stabiliser ou la réduire
un petit peu puis elle repart à la
hausse au ralentissement suivant et au
total bah est sur cette tendance
clairement
croissante or les économistes nous
disent que la définition de la
soutenabilité de la dette publique enfin
celle qui retiennent le plus souvent
c'est que on arrive à stabiliser
justement la dette publique en
pourcentage du PIB c'est pas ce que nous
faisons si on regarde l'évolution des
finances publiques françaises au sens de
cette définition très classique de la
soutenabilité des dettes publiques la
dette publique française n'est pas
soutenable alors elle n'est pas
soutenable vous allez me dire et tout le
monde le constate que ça ne se voit pas
dans les taux d'intérêt puisque bah
finalement la France emprunte toujours
aujourd'hui encore très facilement avec
un taux d'intérêt qui est supérieur à
celui de l'Allemagne mais avec un spread
comme on dit qui ne dépasse
qu'exceptionnellement 60 points de base
et donc bah finalement il y a pas
grand-chose à il y a apparemment pour le
moment les marchés n'ont aucune
inquiétude mon mon interprétation c'est
que s'il ne s'inquiète pas outre mesure
de la dette publique française c'est
parce que que à tort ou à raison ils
sont persuadés que si jamais il ils
émettaient des craintes si jamais les
taux d'intérêt français se mettait tout
d'un coup à augmenter la Banque centrale
européenne serait toujours là pour
intervenir et ne laisserait jamais un
pays comme la France ou même l'Italie
d'ailleurs un grand pays de la zone euro
faire défauts et donc à partir du moment
où bah la France ne risque pas de faire
défaut bah les marchés n'ont pas de
raison de s'inquiéter ils seront
toujours remboursés la France continuera
à rembourser en réempruntant donc il n'y
a pas d'inquiétude alors les marchés
peuvent aussi dans leur analyse regarder
ce qui se passe dans les autres pays
donc si on regarde ce ce qui se passe
dans la zone euro luctolonia l' l'a déjà
bien montré bah on voit que lorsque
l'euro a été créé en
2000 beaucoup de pays de la zone euro
étaient très proche autour du seuil de
60 % du PIB il y avait alors il y avait
deux pays qui étaient nettement
au-dessus qui était l'Italie et la
Belgique mais les autres étaient proches
du seuil et puis quand on regarde leur
évolution et leur situation maintenant
fin 2022 bah c'est on a divergé il y a
une divergence très nette il y a un
groupe de pays qui est resté proche de
60 % du PIB l'Allemagne qui n'en est pas
très éloigné ou nettement en dessous
comme les Pays-Bas et puis bah il y en a
d'autres comme la France ou l'Espagne
qui sont monté très nettement au-dessus
de 100 % du PIB et comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure Luc tolonia quand on regarde la
situation de la zone euro à la fin de
2022 on a six pays qui ont une dette
supérieur à 100 % du PIB j'ajouterai que
ils sont tous au sud de l'Europe sauf la
Belgique et 13 autres pays de la zone
euro qui ont une dette inférieure à 85 %
du PIB donc un écart de 15 points et qui
sont tous Sonor sauf Malte et Chypre
donc il y a un clivage Nord-Sud dans la
zone euro qui est très important qui moi
m'inquiète pour pour l'avenir pour la
cohésion de la zone euro et pour je ne
suis pas sûr que les nouvelles règles
budgétaire européenne on en parlera
peut-être plus euh après avec les
questions mais je ne suis pas sûr que
ces nouvelles règles budgétaires
conduisent à refaire converger euh les
pays de de la zone euro donc on on est
aujourd'hui dans cette situation alors
vous vous vous nous avez demandé de
parler aussi un peu de de la croissance
économique bon je suis pas un
macroéconomiste mais par curiosité j'ai
regardé qu'elle avait été la la
croissance des pays de la zone euro la
croissance du PIB réel depuis depuis
2000 depuis la la création de l'euro et
je je constate que la croissance de la
France et de l'Allemagne ont été
quasiment la même c'est un peu moins de
30 % sur ces 22 sur ces 22 années un peu
moins de 30 % et c'est à peu près la
moyenne de l'Union européenne et de la
zone euro c'est pas très étonnant compte
tenu du poids de la France et
l'Allemagne on a des pays qui ont fait
nettement moins bien l'Italie a fait
nettement moins bien l'Espagne a fait
nettement mieux en revanche mais bon
j'ai pas cherché j'ai pas fait de de
d'études statistiqu particulière mais
j'ai pas l'impression qu'il ait une
corrélation et encore moins une
causalité entre la je dirais la
trajectoire des finances publiques et la
croissance du PIB en tout cas sur ces 20
dernières
années alors que peut-on dire de l'av ir
pour les finances publiques françaises
bah l'avenir d'abord la référence pour
l'avenir c'est la loi de programmation
des finances
publiques loi de programmation des
finances publiques elle prévoit donc que
le déficit public reviendra un peu en
dessous de 3 % du PIB en 2027 et que la
dette publique diminuera un peu en 2027
par rapport à son niveau
actuel quand je regarde les lois de
programmation des finances publiques et
les programmes de stabilité de la France
depuis qu'ils existent
euh malheureusement j'ai pas pu faire de
graphique mais euh ce graphique est très
connu on voit que tous ces programmes de
stabilité toutes ces lois de
programmation prévoi un retour du
déficit public de la France vers zéro
euh sauf les trois derniers qui se
content de prévoir un retour vers 3 % du
PIB et quand on regarde ensuite quelle a
été l'évolution réelle du déficit public
voilà depuis 25 depuis 22 ans et ben on
s'aperçoit que ils n'ont jamais été
respectés ou plus exactement ils n'ont
été respectés que la première voire la
2uxème année mais jamais après la 2uxè
année je me dis que ce track record
comme disent les économistes
anglo-saxons est quand même pas très bon
et peut laisser planer des doutes sur la
trajectoire qui est présentée dans la
loi de programmation actuelle et on a de
bonnes raisons en effet de craindre que
cette trajectoire ne soit pas respectée
d'abord il y a la croissance alors à
nouveau je ne suis pas un prévisionniste
mais je constate quand même que beaucoup
de d'instituts de prévision euh
considèrent que la croissance prévue par
dans cette loie de programmation est un
peu optimiste à commencé d'ailleurs par
la croissance en 2024 cette année euh je
constate aussi que si le le PIB euh une
année donnée est inférieure de 1 point
euh à ce qui était prévu ce qui pourrait
nous arriver euh en 2024 euh de manière
assez automatique il y a une petite
règle de TR très simple mais
relativement fiable qui conduit à penser
que le déficit public toute chose égale
par ailleurs lui-même à ce moment-là est
augmenté de un demi-point de PIB un
point de PIB un point de PIB en moins ça
fait un demi-point de PIB euh de déficit
public en plus ce qui veut dire
d'ailleurs que si voilà si on a un point
de simplement 2024 le PIB est inférieur
de un point à ce qui est dans la loi de
programmation on sera pas si on voilà si
on on décale tous les résultats jusqu'à
2027 on sera pas à 3 % du PIB en dessous
de 3 % du PIB en 2027 de ce simple
fait il y a quand même un élément qui
est quand même en revanche auquel on ne
pense pas souvent qui est peut-être un
peu plus favorable euh aujourd'hui dans
la trajectoire des finances publqu on a
beaucoup dit que dans cette trajectoire
des finances publiques on voyait la
charge d'intérêt augmenter fortement la
charge
d'intérêt dans la trajectoire de
finances publiqu elle repose sur
l'hypothèse que les taux à long terme à
10 ans seront à partir quasiment de 2024
à 3,5 % chaque année voilà de manière
stable c'était on pouvait en effet le
penser en septembre dernier les taux
d'intérêt ont quand même beaucoup baissé
ces derniers temps aujourd'hui depuis le
début de l'année ils sont là j'ai encore
regardé ce matin il est à 38 le taux
d'intérêt à 10 ans français il est à 28
pardon 28 pas 35 à 28 et donc il est
nettement en dessous de 3,5 donc en fait
par rapport à cette trajectoire il y a
peut-être un bonne relativement bonne
nouvelle ok on pourrait avoir une charge
d'intérêt un peu plus faible mais ce
qu'il faut regarder aussi est ce qui en
fait pour moi est le moins crédible dans
cette trajectoire de finances publiques
c'est l'évolution des dépenses publqu
primaire hors charge d'intérêt et là le
Haut Conseil des finances publiques dans
son avis sur la loi de programmation l'a
très bien montré il a calculé
que en fait cette programmation reposait
sur une croissance en volume en Euroc
constant des dépenses publiques
primaires de 01 % moyenne sur les années
2024 2025 2026 2027 01 % quasiment 0 or
le ha Conseil a montré qu' en faisant le
même calcul sur les 25 dernières années
sur des périodes de 4 ou 5 ans sans
crise parce qu'on suppose qu'il y aura
pas de nouvelle crise d'ici 2027 bien on
n'a jamais fait mieux queun croissance
des dépenses publiques de 0,9 % enfin le
le la période sur laquelle cette
croissance a été la plus faible bah ça a
été une croissance moyenne de 0,9 faut
passer de 0,9 à
01 moi je ne sais pas comment on peut y
arriver je ne sais pas euh je je pense
que c'était déjà très difficile en
France de de faire ce qui a été ce qu'on
a fait dans le passé je pense que c'est
encore plus difficile aujourd'hui après
de ou 3 ans de quoi qu'il en coûte j'ai
toujours dit que le quoi qu'il en coûte
était nécessaire il fallait le faire en
2020- 20021 il fallait prendre des
mesures temporaires et exceptionnelles
très importantes pour soutenir
l'activité mais il fallait que ces
mesures restent temporaires je pense
qu'elles resteront temporaires en effet
bon on vac vers une suppression des diff
des divers boucliers mais
psychologiquement je pense que quand
même le le le le gros problème c'est que
ça a quand même laissé entendre beaucoup
de gens que les milliards pouvaient
couler à flot et que bah il y avait pas
besoin de faire des efforts on pouvait
avoir un des dépenses publiques un
déficit et une dette publique qui
augmente indéfiniment et donc ça a
renforcé cette opinion qui était quand
même déjà assez présente en France
depuis très longtemps et qui peut
expliquer en partie
cette trajectoire dans le passé que je
vous ai
décrite merci
Monsieur Je je je sais pas comment
d'ailleurs parler de votre intervention
pour dire si elle était vraiment
optimiste ou quoi bon
bien je je me tourne donc maintenant
vers monsieur jérô CREL qui donc lui est
économiste et qui nous apportera donc
son regard d'économiste vous avez publié
de nombreux papiers sur les sujets qui
nous intéressent aujourd'hui donc quel
est le lien on va y revenir entre les
trajectoires des finances publiques et
la croissance économique on a eu
quelques premièr premières idées
existe-t-il un consensus parmi les
économistes ou subsiste-t-il encore des
divergences sur ces questions on peut
supposer que oui parce que là où il y a
un monde d'économie d'économiste il y a
quand même des positions nuancées on va
dire ça comme ça quel est l'impact de la
situation économique des finances
publiques d'un état sur les autres États
de la de la zone euro voilà les quelques
questions qu'on vous avez soumises mais
bien entendu vous pouvez ouvrir
davantage le sujet merci monsieur le
Président merci madames et Messieurs les
les sénateurs
euh merci chers collègues pour vos
propos introductifs je vais essayer
d'être d'être complémentaire aux propos
qui ont été qui ont été tenus euh et et
essayer donc d'évoquer les les trois
questions que monsieur le Président
vient de vient de me poser reparler un
petit peu de dette publique lié déficit
public politique budgétaire et
croissance et s'interroger un petit peu
sur les cout qu'engendrerait une
austérité budgétaire le terme a pas
encore été évoqué mais je pense qu'il
est il est temps de de l'évoquer et puis
reparler des règles budgétaires et des
débats qu' qui vont ouvrir sur notamment
les questions de coordination alors si
si je peux me permettre je je vais
commencer
par revenir sur les les les dettes
publiques en proption du PIB donc Luc
tolonia les a les a déjà présenté moi
j'ai j'ai souhaité choisir quelques
années en particulier donc laanéance de
l'euro
1999 2023 les données prévues pour la
fin d'année d'année dernière donc ce
sont pas des données définitive de dett
publique sur PIB et puis des années un
petit peu un petit peu charnières 2007
juste avant que ne s'enclenche la crise
financière internationale 2014 quand on
sort enfin de la crise financière
internationale et de la crise dite des
dettes souveraines crise européenne 2019
juste avant qu'on tombe en 2020 sur la
crise de covid pour pour essayer de je
voulais faire ça pour essayer de tirer
quelques quelques enseignements d'abord
la première chose qui est frappante et
que mes deux collègues ont déjà
répertorié c'est que les dettes
publiques ont augmenté entre 1999 et
2023 en dépit des de phases
d'accélération de croissance de
décélération et de récession même de
économique on a maintenant des des des
ratios dett sur piip qui ont beaucoup
augmenté on était relativement proche
pour la zone euro des 60 % à la
naissance de l'euro on est maintenant
proche des 90 % du PIB on a quand même
pris beaucoup de dett publique au au fil
de ces 25 premières années de de l'euro
ça c'est un premier renseignement et
cette augmentation des dettes on la
trouve pour pour tous les tous les
États-membres mais évidemment et c'est
quelque chose qui a déjà été souligné il
y a beaucoup d'hétérogénéité entre les
États-membres avec des pays qui avaient
fait beaucoup d'efforts d'ajustement
budgétaire notamment l'Espagne qui en
2007 avait beaucoup baissé son ratio de
dette sur piible et qui finalement après
toutes ces toutes ces crises économiques
se retrouvent avec un ratio de dette sur
piible supérieur à à 100 % du PIB donc
les dettes ont augmenté les dettes ont
augmenté au gré des crises économiques
donc entre 2007 et 2014 entre 2019 et
2020 donc on voit effectivement les
dettes publiques augmenté au gré des
crises on voit également les dettes
publiques sur PIB diminuer après les
crises c'est un quelque chose qui a déjà
été souligné par mes par mes deux par
mes deux collègues il y a une
possibilité quand même de voir les
ratios dettes sur PIB diminuer d'année
en année même si en tendance longue
comme vient de le rappeler François cal
on a quand même des augmentations assez
considérables de ratio de de dett sur
PIB dans dans ce dans ce florilège de de
de de d'éléments factuels il y a quand
même deux pays qui se distinguent du lot
deux trois pays qui se distinguent du
lot donc l'Italie qui continue d'avoir
une un ratio de dett sur PIB
considérable mais c'est pas ce pays sur
lequel je voulais m'apesantir je voulais
parler de l'Allemagne d'abord puisque
l'Allemagne a démarré l'Euro avec 60 %
de dett sur PIB elle finit l'année 2023
avec pratiquement 60 % de dett sur PIB
et je pense que c'est un élément
important dans les négociations qu'il y
a actuellement autour des règles
budgétaires puisqu'il y a un État membre
puissant l'Allemagne qui peut quand même
en remontrer aux autres en disant voilà
ben on s'est donné un un une règle
budgétaire de convergence vers un ratio
de 60 % du PIB et nous allemands sommes
parvenus et malgré toutes les crises que
nous avons nous aussi allemand subi donc
je pense que c'est c'est un élément
important dans les négociations
politiques qu'il y ait dans cette
enceinte un bon élève ou un état qui va
se présenter comme un bon élève et dans
cette même enceinte il y aura un un
autre pays qui moins bon élève qui est
la France qui est la France qui pendant
des périodes au cours desquelles nous
n'avions pas de crise économique entre
1999 et 2007 donc avant la crise
économique entre 2014 quand nous
sortions d'une crise européenne et 2019
bah la France a continué de voir son
ratio de dett sur PIB augmenter très
légèrement mais très différemment de
l'ensemble des autres étatsmembres de de
la zone euro et le dernier point sur ce
sur ce graphique que je voulais
mentionner c'est bon les dettes
publiques ont augmenté certes certains
pays respectent un peu moins bien les
règles budgétaires que d'autres certes
mais si on compare la situation de la
zone euro et des États-membres de la
zone euro avec celle des États-Unis
d'Amérique qui évidemment pas un pays
européen mais qui est ici aussi sur ce
graphique mais on constate que les
États-Unis d'Amérique ont une
trajectoire de finances publiqu dont
semble s'inspirer la France les états
États-Unis ont vu leur ratio dette sur
PIB augmenter quasiment chaque année
malgré les crises et en dépit des
périodes d'accélération la croissance
économique en 1999 aux États-Unis on a
un ratio de dette sur PIB inférieur à 60
% du PIB aujourd'hui il est du double
d'accord et la question de la
soutenabilité des finances publiques
américaines ne se pose quasiment jamais
elle se pose sans doute politiquement
entre les prétendants à la présidence
des États-Unis d'Amérique mais elle ne
s'ppose pas parmi les économistes on se
pose pas vraiment cette question alors
est-ce que nous Français pouvons en
tirer des enseignements c'est plus
difficile évidemment d'en tirer des
entraisignements et notamment du fait de
l'augmentation assez importante des taux
d'intérêt he les taux d'intérêt à 10 ans
sur la dette publique ont augmenté assez
considérablement et très rapidement
depuis 2022 ce qui va forcément
renchérir le coût des nouvelles
émissions de dettes publiques des
différents étatsmembres qu'il s'agisse
de la France ou ici de la zone euro
l'augmentation des taux d'intérêt donc
les taux d'intérêt à long terme étaent
proche de zéro en sur l'année 2022 ils
sont maintenant plus proches donc de 2,8
3 % donc dans le programme de stabilité
est indiquer que ce serait 3,4 % on est
peut-être un peu en de ça mais les taux
d'intérêt on ont fortement augmenté ils
ont augmenté on le sait très bien pour
lutter contre l'inflation et l'inflation
l'inflation est bien plus forte que
l'augmentation des taux intérêts
nominaux donc nos taux d'intérêt
corrigés de l'inflation reste négatif
sinon proche de zéro donc on n'a pas non
plus un emballement des taux d'intérêt
réels mais une augmentation du coût de
refinancement de nos dettes alors cette
augmentation des des dettes publiques
sur PIB qu'on constate pose la question
de la soutenabilité des dettes publiques
en général pour discutter de
soutenabilité des des dettes publiques
les
économistes utilisent de deux métriques
différentes la première consiste à se
poser la question de savoir si il y a un
effet boule de neige est-ce que si un
gouvernement parvient à n'avoir aucun
déficit public sa dette publique va
continuer d'augmenter la réponse sera
oui en dépit d'un déficit des finances
publiques Nules la dette publique sur pi
peut continuer d'augmenter si les
charges d'intérêt sur la dette
augmentent plus vite que la croissance
économique c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'écart entre le taux d'intérêt sur la
dette mettons à 10 ans et le taux de
croissance nominale de l'économie et
comme vous pouvez le constater sur le
graphique qui est à gauche que j'ai tiré
d'une note de la direction général du
Trésor on a eu toutes sortes d'évolution
au cours du temps euh de ce cet écart
critique entre le taux d'intérêt sur la
dette et le taux de croissance de
l'économie entre les années 50 et la fin
des années 70 cet écart critique est
négatif donc on n pas d'effet boule de
neige on est dans une situation où à
déficit nul euh déficit public nul on
peut voir le ratio d' sur PIB euh
diminuer depuis le début des années 80
ce cet écart critique est devenu positif
il est très fluctuant mais ce qui est
une bonne nouvelle pour l'évolution
future de nos finances publiques si les
prévisions qui ont été faites par le
gouvernement dans le programme de
stabilité de 2023 sont exactes c'est que
cet écart critique pour la France est
négatif en 2022 négatif en 2023 et qu'il
est prévu qu'il reste négatif voire
proche de zéro en 2026 et 2027 qu'est-ce
que ça signifie ça signifie que selon le
gouvernement il n'est pas attendu
d'effet boule de neige de l'augmentation
des taux d'intérêt nominaux sur le ratio
dette sur PIB grâce à la croissance
nominale al ça c'est une première
maîtrique qui nous laisserait imaginer
que il y a pas trop de de problème à
court terme de d'évolution enfin de
d'insoutenabilité de la dette publique
française ou européenne l'autre métrique
elle est pas relative au déficit public
total mais au déficit public moins les
charges d'intérêt sur la dette ce qu'on
appelle le le le déficit primaire et
comme vous pouvez le constater sur ce
sur ce graphique également après que ce
déficit primaire a considérablement
augmenté jusqu'à atteindre jusqu'à 6 %
du PIB voire 8 % du PIB pour la France 6
% du PIB pour la zone euro et bien
depuis la crise de covid-19 nous voyons
ce déficit primaire se résorber
progressivement pas à des rythmes
exceptionnels mais on a des
gouvernements qui mettent en place des
des des lois de programmation budgétaire
leur permettant de réduire année après
année le leur déficit primaire j'ai j'ai
souhaité aussi montrer le déficit
primaire de des États-Unis d'Amérique
rappelez-vous 120 % de dett publi les
États-Unis d'Amérique ne semblent pas
trop se soucier de la soutenabilité de
leur leurs finances publiques j'en veux
pour preuve que leur déficit primaire
reste considérable
considérablement élevé dans les années
2024- 2025 tel que prévu par
l'administration de du président Joe
Biden donc la question qui se pose à
nous c'est celle de savoir si face à
cette hausse des taux d'intérêt et la
hausse des dettes publi il y a mise en
péril de nos finances publiques est-ce
que nos dettes deviennent insoutenables
alors il est certain que nos
gouvernement court de plus en plus de
risque d'avoir à rembourser le principal
de leur dette à avec des é mississions
qui vont être plus coûteuses si les taux
d'intérêt restent plus élevés qu'il
n'était dans une
phase précédente l'autre élément qui
n'est pas bon c'est que la Banque
centrale européenne s'est désengagée de
certaines politique de rachat de dett
publique depuis avril 2022 pour le
programme PEP depuis juillet 2022 pour
le programme app et que en plus elle a
augmenté très considérablement et très
rapidement ses tau directeurs ça ce sont
les mauvaise nouvelle pour la
soutenabilité des finances publiques la
bonne nouvelle je la rappelle c'est que
l'écart critique semble-t-il serait
négatif et que les déficits public
primaire sont en voie de de résorption
alors le problème c'est que il s'agit de
de projection alors je voudrais juste
vous dire que les économistes se posent
la question depuis très longtemps hein
de la soutenabilité des finances
publiques et ont essayé de ne pas faire
dépendre cette soutenabilité des
finances publiques de seulement deux
indicateurs l'écart critique et le le le
sur plus le surplu primaire ou le
déficit primaire il y a énormément de
travaux qui sont consacrés à essayer de
de comprendre comment par le passé les
gouvernements ont réagi par leur
politique budgétaire à l'évolution de
leur dett publique la question que se
posent ces économistes est la suivante
est-ce que confronté à une augmentation
de la dette publique un gouvernement va
décider de réduire ses dépenses de telle
sorte à réduire son déficit primaire et
d' assurer une meilleure soutenabilité
de sa dette publique ou pas est-ce qu'on
laisse la dette publique exploser sans
limite ou est-ce qu'on utilise ces
politique budgétaire discrétionnaire
pour le faire est-ce que certains
travaux auquels j'ai pu contribuer ont
conclu travaux avec Pierre Aldama ils
ont conclu au fait que quand on regarde
les pays de l'OCDE quand on regarde les
pays de la zone euro par ce qu'on
constate c'est que en général confronté
à une augmentation de leur dett publique
les gouvernements changent de de braquet
et finissent par mener des politique de
réduction de leurs dépenses ou
d'augmentation de la fiscalité de telle
sorte à réduire le rythme d'augmentation
de leur ratio dette sur PIB mais ce
qu'on a ce qu'on peut constater aussi
dans des travaux que j'ai que j'ai
actualisé qui sont en cours c'est que
dans dans ce dans ce panorama la France
fait un peu figure d'exception c'estd
que il y a beaucoup de travaux qui
consistent aussi à se dire ben quand on
se pose cette question de la
soutenabilité il y a des périodes au
cours desquelles on voit des
gouvernements qui ne s'en soucient pas
du du tout il laisse la dette augmenter
et puis des périodes au cours desquelles
le gouvernement s'ans souci et réduit la
voilure de telle sorte à réduire le le
le le déficit primaire et l'alternance
de ces deux situations aboutit au fait
que sur le temps long bah la dette elle
reste soutenable mais quand on compare
par exemple la la France à l'Allemagne
ou à l'Italie B ce qu'on constate c'est
que la France a des régimes soutenables
et des régimes insoutenables mais quand
elle a des régimes soutenables elle fait
pas grand-chose pour que ça le soit
c'està-dire que la soutenabilité de la
dette publique par l'état français sa
réaction budgétaire de telle sorte à
assurer sa soutenabilité et la plus
faible possible alors que les Italiens
sont prêts à faire de très gros efforts
pour assurer la soutenabilité de leur
dette publique donc il a vraiment un
pays faisant un peu figure d'exception
malheureusement c'est c'est le pays dans
lequel nous sommes la France qui est
habitué comme le rappeler François ECAL
a faire du déficit et de la dette il y a
pas de problème de
soutenabilité budgétaire pour la France
mais c'est vrai qu'on mène pas les
politiques les plus adéquates
comparativement à à nos partenaires
européens alors ce ce qui ce qui pose la
question suivante qui est celle de
savoir bon si on rentre dans une
situation au cours de laquelle on trouve
que les déficits publics ont trop
augmenté B il va falloir Moder des
politiques pour commencer de les
stabiliser voire de réduire les ratios
de dettes sur PIB et donc ça la question
de savoir s'il faut se lancer dans des
politiques d'austérité budgétaire ou de
consolidation
budgétaire alors la première question
qui doit se poser à nous c'est si on
doit entamer une telle politique
d'austérité bah par quel moyen doit-elle
passer est-ce qu'il s'agit de réduire
les dépenses ou d'augmenter les recettes
parce que on a parlé pas mal pour
l'instant de réduire les dépenses ou ou
d'augmenter les dépenses les dépenses
augmentent augmentent on regarde pas la
fiscalité on se pose pas la question de
savoir si par la levée de nouveaux
impôts par l'augmentation de certains
taux d'imposition l'État ne permet
n'aurait pas de nouvelles recette
budgétaire qui contribueraiit à réduire
son ratio d'ê sur piip et le risque
qu'on prend à vouloir mener une
politique d'austérité budgétaire c'est
qu'en se posant pas cette question du
bon moyen pour y parvenir on fasse ce
qu'on a souvent fait par le passé
c'est-à-dire qu'on taille dans des
dépenses publiques qu'on qualifie d'un
door à court terme en général on avait
prévu de faire des grands programmes
d'investissement public en faveur de
l'hôpital en faveur de l'éducation en
faveur de la transition écologique bon
on a plus les moyens bah on ne mènera
pas à terme ces programmes
d'investissement public on a réduit les
dépenses publiques prévues ce qui va
contribuer à réduire le déficit public
et donc c'est c'est quelque chose sur
lequel je vais revenir assez brièvement
et assez assez rapidement c'est la
question de l'investissement public donc
ça ça c'est une première question baisse
des dépenses ou hausse de la fiscalité
puis ensuite c'est la question qu'il
faut se poser c'est est-ce qu'on a été
capable de de tirer les leçons de la
crise grecque alors les règles
budgétaires sont pas ultra souples
telles qu'elles apparaissent aujourd'hui
elles sont quand même largement consacré
à la soutenabilité de la dette publique
donc c'est pas tout à fait sûr qu'on ait
tiré les leçons de la la crise grecque
et mais il y a une leçon que les
économistes ont semble-t-il tirer de la
crise grecque c'est celle de
mesurer le coût économique d'une cure
d'austérité
budgétaire donc ça s'appelle l'effet
multiplicateur et donc je vais passer
très brièvement je sais que notre temps
est compté que je suis je suis un peu
long je m'en excuse je voudrais juste
vous rappeler quelques quelques points
François ECAL a relié croissance
économique et déficit public mais le
problème des déficits public c'est
qu'ils sont liés à la croissance de deux
façons si la croissance économique se
détériore les déficits publics vont
tendance à avoir euh euh ils vont avoir
tendance pardon à augmenter d'accord
donc il y a forcément une première
causalité la causalité qui qui nous
intéresse plus particulièrement c'est
celle de savoir si lorsqu'un
gouvernement mène une politique
budgétaire discrétionnaire est-ce que
cette politique budgétaire
discrétionnaire aura les effets réels
escomptés est-ce que si vous faites une
cure d'austérité vous allez réduire la
l'activité économique est-ce que quand
vous allez faire une stimulation
budgétaire vous allez augmenter
l'activité économique
et l'état de l'art aujourd'hui est très
consensuel j'y viens dans une seconde je
commence par le cas américain avec les
papè que sont Valérie Ramy et Sarah
zubairi qui sont les plus grandes
spécialistes et expertes des questions
de finances publiqu en macroéconomie aux
États-Unis qui conclut qu'une politique
budgétaire
expansionniste discrétionnaire aux
États-Unis va provoquer un effet
multiplicateur de 1,3 % à court terme et
de 0,8 % à long terme qu'est-ce que ça
signifie ça signifie que si les
États-Unis d'Amérique font un plan de
stimulation budgétaire d'un point de PIB
à une date donnée le PIB dans ce pays
augmentera d'1,3 % de plus qu'il
n'aurait augmenté sans cette stimulation
budgétaire et de 0,8 % à l'horizon de 5
années d'accord donc c'est c'est un
effet positif et relativement fort et
d'autres travaux menés par Nakamura et
aboutissent à des conclusions assez
assez similaires avec des effets
multiplicateurs positifs d'1,4 ou de 1,8
ça c'est pour l'état de l'art aux
États-Unis je vais pas vous commenter ce
tableau qui est illisible c'est exprès
mais pour vous dire que il y a pas deux
papiers qui dans la littérature
économique qui traite de la question des
effets multiplicateurs il y en a de très
nombreux certains publiés très récemment
je j'ai j'ai tiré ce tableau d'un
travail qui est publié en 2023 dans une
revue V qui s'appelle macrodynamics et
qui va répertorier tous les effets
multiplicateurs qui ont été calculés par
les économistes depuis 2002 si je me
trompe pas avec des méthodes économiques
différentes sur des pays différents il y
a des estimations sur les États-Unis sur
la zone euro sur l'Allemagne sur la
France et cetera et dans ce tableau que
vous qui est totalement éisible le
nombre de points négatif est extrêmement
faible et il tend à disparaître
progressivement quand on nétant le champ
des travaux d'accord donc pendant
longtemps on a essayé de discuter de la
question des politiques budgéaires en
nous disant mais il se pourrait qu'il a
des contractions budgétaires
expansionnistes si on impose au français
une cure d'austérité il devrait s'en
satisfaire parce que ça va vouloir dire
plus de croissance parce que l'État est
est trop grand il prend trop de place
dans l'économie il empêche l'initiative
privée il faut libérer cette initiative
privée sauf que des résultats selon
lesquels ces contractions budgétaires
sont expansionnistes n'existe quasiment
plus dans la littérature littérature
économique ce qu'on constate plutôt
c'est que les politiques budgétaires de
stimulation budgétaire ont des effets
favorables sur l'activité économique et
je termine sur un un un papier qui se
pose la question en Europe de l'impact
que pourrait avoir l'investissement
public sur la croissance économique et
qui conclut à des effets assez
considérables de l'augmentation de
l'investissement public sur l'activité
économique donc investir publiquement
dans les infrastructures euh dans nos
bâtiments dans nos transports
favoriserait également la croissance et
pas simplement l'atteinte d'autres
d'autres d'autres objectifs
environnementaux et j'en termine avec
les les les règles budgétaires donc donc
nous avons des problèmes de dette
publies elles sont élevé il faut
certainement penser à à stabiliser ces
ratios de dett sur PIB est-ce que c'est
cependant une bonne chose que de faire
de l'austérité budgétaire soyons
conscient du fait que si nous faisons
une austérité budgétaire elle sera très
coûteuse pour l'activité économique
est-ce que les règles budgétaires
actuellement discutées vont nous
permettre d'échapper à l'austérité
budgétaire j'ai des doutes j'ai des
doutes je n'ai pas de preuve Luc tolog a
eu bien raison de dire que ces règles
budgétaires sont actuellement en cours
de discussion mais un point important à
rappeler que ces règles budgétaires vont
pas changer tant que ça d'accord puisque
si on veut que tout reste tel que c'est
il faut que rien ne change on n pas du
tout dans dyamp pedusa c'est le
contraire et donc on garde évidemment
les critères de 3 % sur le déficit
public et de 60 % sur la dette ils sont
inscrits en annexe du traité personne ne
semble vouloir ouvrir les traité qui
serait une forme de boîte de Pandore et
le critère de dette reste l'alpha et
l'oméga de la soutenabilité en dépit de
tous les travaux qui ont qui ont
contribuer à imaginer que la
soutenabilité est une affaire de
facteurs macroéconomique et aussi de de
facteurs nationaux mais je voudrais pas
dire du mal des des règles budgétaires
en vigueur les les règles qui sont des
règles plutôt qui sont en réforme ces
ces règles vont dans la bonne direction
je vais très vite dépenses primaires
nettes euh je suis d'accord avec
luupogiaac effectivement c'est une règle
de dépense qui est à la discrétion des
États-membres et des gouvernements euh
au moment où ils prennent leur décision
donc c'est beaucoup plus transparent
pour eux euh d'assurer une meilleure
trajectoire de leurs finances publiques
et pour la commission de de surveiller
cette trajectoire les trajectoires vont
devenir individuelles donc on n'est plus
dans une vision très homogène de
trajectoire de des dépenses publiques
donc ça c'est plutôt une une bonne chose
si ça se confirme les dépenses cycliques
d'indemnité chômage sont préservées ce
qui va permettre de rendre nos
politiques budgétaires plus
contratcycliques quand on a besoin
d'augmenter les dépenses d'indemnisation
chômage parce qu'on rentre en récession
ben on ne sera pas obligé de faire une
cure d'austérité pour compenser donc je
pense que ça c'est important les
périodes d'ajustement budgétaires sont
rallongé et puis on nous dit que les
réformes structurelles et les
investissements publics seront préservés
et j'ai ajouté sur le papier parce que
c'est sur ce point-là que il y a pas
beaucoup de de de clarté euh sur la les
déceptions euh on a un retour en force
de la numérologie hein parce que comme
je l'écrit il y a des critères de
finances publiques partout dans les
documents que la Commission a a a rendu
publique le le 20 décembre dernier euh
c'était pas son intention à la
commission parce que les propositions
qui avaient été fait en 2022 ne
comportaiit pas autant euh de de de euh
de de chiffres et et de nombre donc je
dénombre le 3 % le 60 %, le 90 % le 1 %
le 0,5 % et cetera donc il y a des
critères dans tous les sens sur le la
dette publique sur le déficit public sur
le déficit structurel sur le déficit
structurel primaire donc c'est d'une
complexité inoui qui va rendre la
gestion des finances publiques
extrêmement absconse pour le grand
public et pour à mon avis les
parlementaires d'accord pour le suivi
des finances publiques je pense que
c'est c'est impossible à suivre
avec le retour des sols structurels on
voit revenir la croissance potentielle
donc qui est une valeur non observable
une variable non observable donc ça pose
ça pose évidemment question parce que
c'est un moyen d'instrumentaliser le le
débat de politique budgétaire et puis le
dernier point que je voulais soulever
c'était celui de l'absence finalement de
dimension collégiale européenne sur les
questions de finances
publiques il y a une volonté dans cette
proposition de réforme du cadre
budgétaire européen de rendre le la
place du European fiscal board du
Conseil budgétaire européen beaucoup
plus importante mais ce qui va renforcer
le poids d'une forme de technocratie
dans le suivi et la surveillance des
politiques budgétaires avec beaucoup
moins d'appropriation par les par les
par les parlementaires et une chose que
moi je je trouve décevante c'est que le
Parlement européen ne trouve pas une une
place plus importante dans la gestion
des finances publiques européennes
pardon comme en France mais mais que au
Parlement européen également parce que
comme le président Claude renal le
rappelait il y a beaucoup d'effet de
débordement des politiques budgétaires
de l'une vers l'autre donc j'en
ai montré quelquesunes donc il y a un
certain nombre de travaux qui montrent
justement que la politique budgétaire
choisie par un étatmembre a des
répercussions sur les autres
États-membres une relance budgétaire en
Allemagne aura potentiellement des
effets favorables sur la France donc il
serait bon que la France tienne compte
avant de décider elle-même de sa
stratégie de finances publi puisque si
elle bénéficie de la croissance importée
de l'Allemagne peut-être n'avons-nous
pas à faire autant de relance budgétaire
et peut-être pouvons-nous faire un peu
de réduction de notre dette publ donc
ces élémentsl ne sont pas du tout
discutés politiquement ils le sont
certainement derrière des des portes
clauses dans le cadre du du Conseil
entre la Commission et les États-membres
mais jamais par des parlementairire et
c'est la raison pour laquelle je ne
comprends pas qu'il n'y ait pas plus de
dialogue budgétaire au niveau européen
entre les États-membres et les
représentants des États-membres au
Parlement européen je vous remercie de
votre
attention merci beaucoup merci beaucoup
monsieur pour
cette vision consolidée on va dire euh
sur cette question qui est éminemment
complexe donc euh je vais vous demander
mes chers collègues de vous inscrire
pour pouvoir organiser un petit peu un
petit peu le le débat euh et répartir
les les temps de parole aussi entre
entre les groupes euh donc d'abord
monsieur le rapporteur général
Jean-François hon oui merci euh merci
monsieur le Président merci messieur
pour les euh comment dirais-je les
différentes expressions qui sont les
vôtres que je trouve
finalement assez convergente est-ce qui
ne va pas me
rassurer qui croise largement le point
de vue que le Sénat a exprimé sur la
question des finances
publiques alors juste j'ai j'ai j'ai
entendu souvent le mot
austérité je pense qu'on peut alors il y
avait aussi rigueur la rigueur
budgétaire et je dis toujours la
budgetaire être rigoureux dans sa vie
dans ses actes c'est une qualité quand
on est rigoureux ça veut pas dire qu'on
est austère je le dis parce que je je
vois très bien ce que ça implique
derrière et et on peut donner quelques
exemples on a voulu être un peu
rigoureux la majorité sénatoriale en
proposant des pistes d'économie au
gouvernement lors du PLF puisque nous
avons nous fait la totalité de l'examen
budgétaire au moins on a on a un sujet
on pose une copie 7 milliard d'économie
retenue même pas l'ureau symbolique
voilà ça c'est comme ça c'est comment
dirais-je le sujet posé peut-être
au-delà du
commentaire vous interroger
collectivement sur et vous l'avez dit
finalement la France est est quand même
depuis quelques années depuis un certain
temps le mauvais élèv de l'Europe
puisque à de manière quasi permanente le
déficit budgétaire la dette publique
s'accroisse et il n'est pas o il est
moins servi par la croissance économique
puisque on peut pas la décider quand
même tout à fait tout seul pour le pays
même l'Europe et la croissance mondiale
étant euh euh assez euh chauté donc
peut-être selon vous quel quels sont les
les pays européens dont la trajectoire
les politiques conduites vous paraissent
les plus vertueuses en tous les cas
peut-être des exemples à suivre et et je
le dis notamment puisque on voit que
depuis 2017 alors je prends pas vous le
devinez bien tout à fait par hasard
cette date on a une chance on a le même
ministre ça fait 7 ans c'est la grande
descente depuis 7 ans donc on
peut expliquer ce qu'on veut mais moi
mon sujet c'est c'est
comment selon vous on pourrait concilier
la maîtrise des de nos finances
publiques avec une une
croissance je dirais économique j'aurais
je dirais même presque une croissance
durable plus soutenue parce que je ne je
ne jette pas tout je pense que on ne
peut pas je dis croissance dur vous
l'avez compris c'est parce que je pense
que la question budgétaire les enjeux
financiers et de dett sont très
importants je pense qu'il faut aussi les
corréler comment dirais-je
avec pragmatisme avec les enjeux
écologiques qui sont aussi etclimatiques
des enjeux majeurs et puis je je pour ne
pas être trop long je je vous poserai
une question sur effectivement l'accord
du 20 décembre est-ce qu'il vous
paraît être
plutôt une une espèce de de de compromis
ou de vision convergente venant de rive
ou de points de vue assez différent pour
pas dire opposé au départ ou alors c'est
finalement comment dirais-je le notre
partenaire l'Allemagne
qui imprime fortement les orientations
dans le cadre de ce dialogue
européen
merci Monsieur rapporteur général je
vous indique messieur que pour les
réponses nous débarrerons dans l'ordre
inverse don monsieur directeur vous
conclurez et également vous prendrez les
éléments de réponse enfin de question
qui vous intéressent plus
particulièrement bien
entendu donc Thierry tout d'abord avec
éri be qui se
prépare merci merci monsieur le
Président merci messieurs pour vos prés
pour vos présentations qui qui nous
éclair une question le le le 17 janvier
dernier là le le Parlement vient à adopt
le la réforme du PACT de stabilité et de
croissance euh cette réforme propose une
période d'ajustement de 4 ans aux États
dont la dette et le déficit sont
supérieurs aux règles de maastr pour
ramener leur compte public sur une
trajectoire budgétaire jugé ça été le
débat ce matin soutenable la période
d'ajustement pourrait être allongée
jusqu'à 7 ans si les États-membres
adoptent et je cite
des réformes structurelles considérées
comme susceptibl d'améliorer la
résilience financière dans le même temps
la commission fixe fixera des programmes
budgétaires pour les États dont la dette
publique dépasse 90 % du PIB afin qu'il
réduise leur dette d'un point de PIB
chaque année tout au long de la durée de
leur plan de dépenses national
globalement ce qu'on peut noter c'est
que les règles sont encore plus opaques
voire si vous me le permettez
incompréhensible là où l'obj objectif
était de les rendre plus lésible ce que
ce que j'en retiens c'est qu'il y a un
très léger rassouplissement avec un
cadre qui ne bouge pas c'est-à-dire le
retour progressif à des
politiques
d'austérité avec un déficit public pour
la France qui frôle les 5 % une dette
publique proche de de
115 pour il est ademi que la France sera
soumis à une procédure déficit excessive
dès le printemps prochain alors que dans
le même temps la loi de program ation
des finances publiques et ça a été
évoqué que nous avons voté en décembre
2023 prévoit un retour du déficit à
moins de 3 % en
2027 donc dans ce contexte la France
apprête comme bon nombre de ces pays
européens à subir la même situation
économique que la dernière décennies
c'est-à-dire une politique d'austérité
et une croissance à tonne d'autant plus
avec des taux d'intérêt élevés à l'heure
où le fossé notamment avec les
États-Unis et aussi toutes les autres
grandes puissances internationales ne
cessent de se creuser et où les besoins
d'investissement sur le vieux continent
sont me semble-t-il majeurs donc la
question est très simple est-ce que vous
pensez qu'aujourd'hui le cadre
maastrichien tel qu'il a été défini
reste le cadre adéquate tant pour les
pays européens que pour la la
construction
européenne merci Thierry BO puis Michel
can oui merci monsieur le Président donc
je vais pas amputer le temps de réponse
de nos invités parce que j'ai pas
vraiment de questions c'est plus des
réactions commentaires à ce qu'on entend
à propos de déficit et de dette
euh tout d'abord on on a évoqué le cas
des
États-Unis États-Unis première puissance
économique du monde ils ont une dette de
31400 milliards de dollars mais ils ont
un système magique aux États-Unis ils
ont le plafond de la dette publique vous
savez ça le plafond de la qui relève en
cas de besoin ça s'est produit il y a
quelques mois et depuis 1960 ils ont
relevé le plafond de la dette américaine
à 78
reprises avec un accord entre démocrat
républicain ok on augmente le plafond de
la dette tu me fais quelques mesures
d'austérité et cetera et cetera bref
78 fois on a augmenté le plafond de la
dette américaine et ça n'a jamais
empêché les États-Unis la première
puissance économique du monde je dis ça
parce que il faut un peu relativiser
cette histoire de ratio de dett sur
PIB qui n'a de sens que le sens qu'on
lui donne je viens de parler des
États-Unis on pourrait citer le cas du
Japon le ratio de dette sur PIB au Japon
vous le connaissez il est à 250 %. et il
y a pas de débat sur la dette publique
au Japon parce que la dette japonaise
est détenue par les Japonais eux-mêmes
ils sont pas dépendants des marchés
financiers extérieurs ça fait une grande
différence
euh notre dette nous donc depuis 74 elle
croit ça a été rappelé dans les débats
on a voté le 50e budget en déficite de
ce pays alors au-delà des crises
effectivement la dette évolue mais on
est en déficit depuis 50 années et c'est
pas prêt de s'arrêter puisqu'on va
réemprunter cette année 285 milliards
d'euros et cetera et cetera on a évoqué
le cas de la dette grecque vous sonnez
de la le drame que le peuple grec a vécu
au moment de la crise 2009 2010 et à
l'époque la Troïa Commission européenne
Banque centrale européenne FMI c'est
comme ça qu'on les appelait avait
demandé aux Grecs de faire des efforts
pour redresser leurs comptes on leur
imposé une purge austéritaire terrible
on a imposé la privatisation d'actifs
économiqu je pense au port du Piret par
exemple on a réduit le nombre de PO de
fonctionnaire on a baissé les pensions
baissé les salaires voilà et en 2010 la
dette grecque était à 330 milliards
d'euros représenta 147,5 % de leur PIB
et 2023 4e trimestre 2023 cette dette
est à 355 milliards d'euros
168,6 % du PIB donc on a rien réglé et
le le peuple grec va pas mieux loin
s'ans faut il suffit de de se renseigner
alors vous avez employé monsieur CREL le
mot austérité vous allez fâcher Monsieur
le Maire qui se défend de nous présenter
des budgets austéritaires enfin c'est un
autre débat dernier élément sur cette
histoire de chiffre la dette de la
France au lendemain de la 2è guerre
mondiale elle était à 160 % du PIB et
vous l'avez rappelé en 1980 on était à
20 %. on a divisé par 8 non pas par une
politique austéritaire mais par une
politique de croissance de développement
des grands équipements des grands
investissements publics et cetera et
cetera je va pas avoir un discours
nostalgique mais il y a des leçons à
tirer à mon avis de cette histoire là la
dette ne se règle pas par l'austérité ça
je n'y crois pas un instant alors on
nous dit les gens ne s'inquiètent pas de
la dette les gens ne s'inquiètent pas de
la dette publique aujourd'hui et c'est
vrai quand vous regardez les
préoccupations en ce moment c'est le
pouvoir d'achat on le comprend la dette
ça vient en 89e position voilà mais
quelque part ce que les gens vivent et
entendent je me souviens de la réplique
de Monsieur Macron interrogé par une
infirmière au CSU de rouan en 2018 il
faisait une visite et il a répondu à
cette dame qui demandait des moyens des
postes des lits madame il n'y a pas
d'argent magique
arrive la crise du covid 2020 et je me
souviens qu'ici dans nos débats au Sénat
novembre- décembre 2019 Bruno Le Maire
Gérald armanin à l'époque au compte
public nous disait attention le ratio de
dette publique est à 98,1 1 % nous
approchons des 100 % sous-entendu demain
c'est l'apocalypse on se souvient de ce
qui s'est passé au mois de mars
l'économie marchande s'arrête la dette
explose et on a trouvé en quelques mois
400 milliards pour continuer à financer
les salaires à ce que les gens
continuent à manger à souder les
entreprises les PGE les reports de
cotisation hein la dette est passée de 2
380 milliards en 2019 à 3088 aujourd'hui
donc l'argent magique qui n'existait pas
on l'a trouvé de manière tout à fait
miraculeuse quelques mois plus tard
comment voulez-vous que les gens
aujourd'hui on doiv leur expliquer qu'il
faut continuer à faire les économies
puisqueà un moment donné quand ça allait
très mal dans le monde en Europe et dans
notre pays on a trouvé les moyens de
faire face à la situation le problème
c'est que maintenant la facture on la
présente aux gens c'est ça le souci donc
voilà voilà ce que je voulais un peu
dire là-dessus et terminer sur une
boutade alors je vais pas vous la faire
en picard je vous la faire en français
mais j'avais un vieux copain dans le
Nord qui me disait on dort mieux avec
des dettes qu'avec des
puces
bon nous étions donc dans le
commentaire alors nous nous poursuivons
alors je je fais un petit tour des
groupes hein aussi Michel Canevet et
puis Isabelle briquet se
prépare merci monsieur le Président je
voudrais remercier aussi nos
intervenants comme l'a rappelé le
rapporteur général tout à l'heure nous
sommes ici plutôt partisan d'une
certaine orthodoxie
budgétaire en tout cas c'est la la
marque de fabrique de la majorité r
sénatorial et et j'ai bien entendu le
propos de notre collègue Éric Boquet
prenant le le l'intérêt de de de
l'endaidement public et j'ai entendu
aussi tout à l'heure nos intervenants
notamment du côté de l'Union européenne
preneit de nouvelles règles budgétaires
monsieurcal nous dire que finalement les
taux d'intérêt restent bas donc la
situation pourrait s'améliorer au plan
de l'endettement et puis du côté de de
l'OFCE nous évoquer que la dépense
publique a effectivement un effet
d'entraînement tout à fait positif sur
l'économie et donc peut-être qu'il faut
s'addicter à à à la dépense publique
alors ceci étant moi je reste sur l'idée
que il faut quand même que nous soyons
particulièrement attentif à nos finances
publiques pour ne pas reporter sur les
générations futures
le poids de nos inconséquences
d'aujourd'hui hein puisqu'il y a bien un
moment où il faudra passer à la caisse
où il faudra payer et est-ce que il est
logique que les générations futures aent
un tel fardeau que celui qu'on leur
laisse maintenant alors pour ce qui
concerne la dette nos interrogations
restent vives parce que si nous
bénéficions de taux d'intérêt
aujourd'hui
positif on sait bien que les notations
de la France pourraient très vite se
dégrader du fait que nous ne soyons pas
capable
de réduire la dépense primaire publique
est-ce que cela ne va pas avoir un effet
extrêmement négatif ensuite je voulais
demander si au niveau de la balance
commerciale qui reste à un niveau
extrêmement élevé est-ce qu'il y a un
risque pour notre économie un risque de
récession pour notre économie du fait de
cette un risque sur nos finances
publiques du fait de cette balance
commerciale extrêmement élevée parce que
nous avons là en des investissements
importants à réaliser on sait dans la
transition
énergétique notamment et puis je je
voulais
ensuite interroger nos intervenants sur
le fait de la capacité qu'il josent de
la France à réaliser les programmes
d'économie alors même que nous voyons
bien dans le domaine de la santé par
exemple il y a des besoins de plus en
plus importants aujourd'hui nous
traversons une crise du secteur primaire
qui va sans doute appeler aussi à à des
interven ption publique accrue bah tout
cela fait queon voit bien que les
dépenses risquent de s'amonceler plutôt
que
les économies que nous devrions réaliser
qu'en
pense-t-il effectivement voilà quelques
questions que je voulais
poser merci Michel pardon Isabelle
briquet puis Florence blatri constat
merci monsieur le Président merci à à
nos trois intervenants j'ai été
particulièrement sensible mais cela
n'étonnera personne à la question du du
coût de l' de l'austérité qui a été
évoqué il me semble effectivement que
cette question et et est stratégique en
en matière de de finances publiqu et et
de choix
budgétaire avec la volonté réaffirmé de
diminution des des impôts le
gouvernement entend envoyer un message
positif à l'adresse des classes moyennes
et il est tout à fait légitime de se
préoccuper du du pouvoir d'achat des
classes moyennes qui rencontre
effectivement de de réelle difficultés
ce sont cependant 2 milliards de baisse
d'impôt qui sont annoncés pour
2025 alors qu'il nous faut investir dans
la transition et la sobriété écologique
rattraper notre retard en matière de
recherche et de développement redonner
des moyens nos services publics écol
université hôpital justice et cetera
Michel canevé y a fait allusion aussi
tout à l'heure limiter nos marges de
manœuvre en recette budgétaire c'est
incontestablement affaibl notre société
et notre économie est-ce que question
toute simple hein mais est-ce que l'État
a encore les moyens de diminuer la
fiscalité merci Isabelle Florence
blatrice
contta merci monsieur le Président et
merci à nos intervenants donc avec ma
collègue Christine lavard nous avions
travaillé sur cette réforme du PACT de
stabilité et de croissance et en effet
le le le les règles étaient beaucoup
trop rigides en réalité pas appliqué et
procyclique et il était nécessaire
d'avancer les proposition de la
Commission était quand même extrêmement
ambitieuse néanmoins on constate que les
concessions faites au frugo avec en
particulier les clauses de sauvegarde
notamment la marge de résilience du
déficit et l'obligation de réduire de la
dette d'un point lorsqu'on dépasse les
90 % du PIB sont quand même assez
restrictifes donc est-ce que c'est
concession finalement ne risque pas
d'être contre-productive alors que des
investissements majeurs se profilent on
a évoqué les domaines la transition
écologique la santé l'éducation mais
également la défense
et alors que les économistes américains
évoquent dans leurs travaux le rôle de
l'effet multiplicateur vous l'avez
évoqué monsieur CREL l'Europe n'est-elle
pas finalement à contre-courant avec ses
clauses de sauvegarde quand on sait bien
que les États-Unis n'utilisent n'hésit
pas à utiliser l'arme budgétaire on le
voit avec l'ire
et une question aussi peut-être
subsidiaire mais pour que l'euro
devienne vraiment une zone monétaire
optimale
sans passagers clandestin que faut-il
faire pour avoir cette meilleure
coordination des politique de soutien de
relance et être plus efficace au niveau
global de notre d'autres zones
monétaires je
vous merci Florence Christian Billac
puis Olivier
PAC merci monsieur le
Président merci pour
ces éclairages au différents
intervenants moi aussi même si je suis
un peu ce côté de la commission je suis
pour une
orthodoxie après je me fous complètement
des 3 % parce que ça veut dire 3 % mais
moi je un paysan et les paysans on a
appris à dépenser un peu moins que ce
qu'on gagnait c'est comme
ça marche trich je sais pas où c'est et
je m'en
fous la deè marque que je ferai c'est
que depuis 3 ans que je suis cette
commission de trajectoire en prospective
et en prévision maintenant je prends
beaucoup de pincett parce que si je
ressors les documents qu'on m'a
distribué au précédent union euh rares
sont ceux qui sont tombés justes voilàin
alors bien sû il a aler mais qui nous
dira qu'il n'y aura pas demain un aléa
par rapport à ce qui est prévu
aujourd'hui voilà moi on est ici en
triniici mais franchement moi je crois
que les Français s'en foutent
complètement du taux de prélevement
obligatoire de la part des dépenses
publiques et autres pour eux c'est du
charabia les Français préféreraient
avoir un peu plus de dépass publique et
un taux de prélèvement obligatoire
peut-être supérieur dès lors que les
services publics rendus à la population
serait de meilleure qualité c'est ça que
conteste les Français les Français il
pestent pas contre le taux de PR
obligatoire il pestent contre le manque
de service à
l'hôpital et dans tous les services
publics c'est ça moi que j'entends dans
mes rencontres avec les Français c'est
pas le tau ils ne connaissent pas le tau
ce qui voi c'est que ça marche pas voilà
hein donc il faut une efficacité de de
la gestion publique alors vous avez
parlé de soutenabilité budgétaire voilà
donc ça c'est les initiés mais il y a la
soutenabilité sociale c'est-à-dire que
on a parfois évoqué le mote d'austérité
si vous allez dire aux agriculteurs
aujourd'hui qui parfois ont des revenus
de 700 ou 800 € par mois qu' faut faire
de l'austérité je crains que ça se passe
mal
hein à tous les mal loger si vous allez
parler qu'il faut faire de l'austérité
en matière de logement je crois que ça
se passera mal et aujourd'hui je crois
qu'on manque de vision on manque de
vision sur euh le moyen et long terme et
par exemple dans matière de logement moi
j'attends de voir au-delà du nécessaire
plein logement qui va coûter très cher
quel seraiit pour l'État les effets
indirects qui eux seraient positifs en
manière de ressources FC de ressources
sociales de cotisation et cetera or on n
pas cette vision on traite les dépenses
on traite les recettes que lien entre
les deux et puis
voilà par contre on entend bien ce que
disais je reviens aux agriculteurs ilité
de quoi ils se plain des agriculteurs je
l'avais dit dans une intervention de
passer plus de temps devant l'ordinateur
à remplir les paperaces que sur le
tracteur en train de labourer les viges
les champ on est suradministré des
administrations omniprésentes ce qui
paralysent le pays c'est là qu'il faut
faire de l'austérité c'est là qu'il faut
faire de l'austérité avec des
rémunérations là on n pas 800 € par mois
comme les agriculteurs qui manifeste sur
l'autoroute des rémunération moi quand
j'entends un directeur de fédération
sportive qui a 500000 € de revenu je
veux bien que ce soit important de
diriger une fédération sportive annuel
c'est 100000 € ànuel encore heureux
monsieur le rapporteur si c'était
journalier ça serait scandaleux mais
même annuel ça reste quand même
scandaleux voilà donc moi je crois que
aujourd'hui C ces hyper administrations
ces opérateurs ces agences ces machins
théodu truc et machin là il y a moyen de
faire des économies pour baisser le
déficit
public bien chers collègues vous êtes
passé de la question macro-économique à
la à la micro-économie et au budgétaire
national si je puis dire fait un lien
qui existe bien entendu euh mais voilà
qui nous écarte un peu de du sujet de de
ce matin
alors Olivier Pacou puis j'ai pas
d'autres inscrit à moins qu'il ait des
regrets Olivier pacour bien il y a un
regret bien merci président merci
messieurs pour vos éclairages
effectivement merci aussi à notre
collègue nordiste Eric boet d'avoir
rappelé cet apport du picard
effectivement au bon sens économique
avec ceses ces bons ce dicton et
effectiv notre ami Hugonis se sentait
gratouillé par par les puces alors moi
messieur j'ai une question qui est
volontairement simpliste
peut-être impertinente je sais pas mais
je partage l' vie du rapporteur général
sur le fait que l'austérité n'est pas la
rigueur et que gérer en bon père de
famille c'est pas
être un père fouettard ma question elle
est toute bête il y a un mot que j'ai
pas du tout entendu dans votre exposé et
qu'on entend de moins en moins
d'ailleurs dans les débats économiques
relatif aux finances publiques alors
qu'on l'entendait il y a encore quelques
années c'est celui de la règle d'or
est-ce que la règle d'or vous apparaît
quelque chose de totalement
impertinent totalement décalé même si on
peut y adjoindre des des des conditions
dérogatoires ou autres mais dans un un
fonctionnement sain d'un système
économique national
merci Olivier Arnaud Bazin donc merci
monsieur le Président une remarque très
rapide et une question la remarque moi
je veux bien entendre tout ce qu'on peut
dire sur le caractère abstrait de
certains chiffres de taux de prélèvement
de dett d'argent magique et cetera mais
il y a quand même 50 milliards
d'intérêts à payer cette année et en
2027 ça sera le premier budget de l'État
ça va absorber l'essentiel de l'impôt
sur le revenu et si nous avions ces 50
milliards disponibles parce que nous
n'avions pas ou moins d'intérêt à payer
il me semble que ce serait quelque chose
d'extrêmement concret tout au contraire
dans le budget de l'État ma question
portait sur le lien que vous avez évoqué
entre la dépense publique
et le la croissance avec l'alerte qui
consiste à dire il y a un effet
multiplicateur et si on freine sur les
dépenses on va avoir un effet sur la
croissance bon euh alors à cet égard ma
question est la suivante est-ce qu'il y
a une catégorie de dépenses ou des
catégories de dépenses qu'on pourrait
diminuer de façon moins dangereuse pour
la croissance je suppose que c'est du
côté de ce qu'on appellerait dans les
collectivités territoriales le
fonctionnement et sûrement pas
l'investissement mais est-ce que à
l'intérieur de ces dépenses de entre
guillemets fonctionnement il y en a qui
sont moins dangereuses à freiner que
d'autres du point de vue de la
croissance merci
ARN bien messieurs je vais vous demander
de vos commentaires parce que j'ai senti
moins de questions que beaucoup de
commentaires donc mais si vous voulez
bien reprendre et et en même temps et en
même temps intégrer les questions de nos
collègues donc monsieur kel en premier
alors est- est-ce que je peux commencer
par vous demander de quelle règle d'or
vous parliez s'il vous plaît de quelle
règle d'or parliez-vous alors ce qui
s'impose collectivité on voote pas de
budget en déficit d'accord d'accord ok
non mais parce que vous savez que les
les Allemands ont inventé une autre
règle ultra strict donc voilà donc comme
l'appellation est la même c'est vrai
mais on est en France voilà voilà donc
on parle bien de la
française c'est important que qu'on
sache qu' qu'on soit tous les deux sur
la même longueur d'onde alors merci de
de vos très nombreuses remarques et
commentaires peut-être je vais commencer
par la par réagir au pardon à la
comparaison avec les avec les États-Unis
qui est qui extrêmement importante les
États-Unis qui ont ce ce plafond de
verre qui n'existe pas le plafond de
verre est très souple et vous l'avez dit
à 78 reprises on peut augmenter le
plafond de verre on augmente la dette
c'est quand quand on en a besoin je
pense que ce qui peut-être peut nous
manquer par rapport à ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis un pays qui lorsqu'il a
besoin de faire un déficit public fait
un déficit public lorsqu'il a besoin de
faire une relance budgétaire en fait une
quand il a besoin d'augmenter sa dette
il l'augmente de telle sorte à répondre
aux besoins que le président des
États-Unis un à ce moment-là pense être
ceux de ses concitoyens et bien il y a
un acteur qui est incontournable c'est
la la Réserve fédérale des États-Unis la
banque centrale est unique évidemment
aux États-Unis c'est c'est c'est comme
pour nous sauf que ce qui nous rend la
situation très inconfortable c'est que
cette banque centrale unique la Banque
centrale européenne doit gérer une très
grande diversité de situation de
finances publiques et de situation
économique et tant que nous n'aurons pas
il me semble officiellement un traur en
dernier ressort nous serons contraints
de continuer de discuter de ces règles
budgétaires et de limitation du montant
de de nos déficits et nos dettes
publiques ce qui se pose évidemment dans
des termes extrêmement différents pour
pour les États-Unis c'est ma c'est ma
première remarque la deuxième remarque
c'est vous rappeliez la Grèce et je
pense que ça connecte justement avec ce
que je disais de des effets
multiplicateurs je je me rends bien
compte que tout ça est très abstrait
mais il faut se souvenir qu'on a imposé
et la Troya a imposé une cure
d'austérité budgétaire à la Grèce en
2009 2010 euh sur l'hypothèse sur la
base d'une hypothèse qui était la
suivante la cure d'austérité en Grèce
n'aura aucune répercussion réelle sur
l'économi grec même peut-être que ça
aura des effets favorables parce que
l'effet multiplicateur on s'attend à ce
qu'il soit nul ou négatif vous faites de
la cure d'austérité ça a pas d'effet
réel sur sur l'activité économique ça
provoquera pas de tragédie sauf qu'il a
fallu revoir un peu le logiciel et se
mettre à faire ces nombreux travaux que
j'ai répertorié dans ce tableau
illisible et pour vous dire les
économistes ont travaillé et il conclut
désormais l'effet multiplicateur est
positif on ne peut plus aujourd'hui
engager une cure d'austérité sans savoir
qu'elle aura des effets déplorables sur
les citoyens de ce pays elle réduira la
croissance économique elle réduira les
revenus de l'ensemble des citoyens de ce
pays ça maintenant on le sait donc au
moins on a on a progressé
rigueur et budgétaire pourquoi pas moi
je parlais d'une austérité budgétaire
une volonté manifeste des pouvoirs
publics de réduire discrétionnairement
leurs dépenses publiques de telle sorte
à voir le la dette sur PIB diminuer non
pas en attendant la croissance mais en
attendant une un effet immédiat sur sur
sur sur les finances publiques donc il y
a y a j'ai pas de souci avec la rigueur
en tant que tel ce qui me semble me
poser question c'est le fait de se
lancer dans une politique d'austérité
budgétaire au aujourd'hui et ce que j'ai
aussi dit c'est que dans le cadre des
règles budgétaires qui sont actuellement
discutées il me semble qu'il subsiste un
risque que ce type de cure d'austérité
soit discuté sinon opposé imposé à
certains États-membres à l'horizon 2025
on a gagné une année certainement avec
cette finalisation fin décembre 2023 de
ce qui devrait être le cadre budgétaire
au 1er janvier 2024 il y a toujours pas
d'accord donc on n pas de cadre
budgétaire européen sans doute
l'aurons-nous plutôt
en cours d'année et qui s'imposera
certainement à partir de 2025 donc pour
un pays comme la France donc les
finances publiques sont quand même un
peu dégradées ou depuis longtemps
dégradé ça imposera sans doute des
changements d'orientation j'imagine
plutôt au printemps de l'année prochaine
pas pas au printemps de cette
année sur la la question donc de la de
la règle d'or qui rejoint finalement la
question de savoir quelles dépenses on
pourrait freiner parce que le problème
de la règle d'or c'est c'est de savoir
aussi quel type de pense on exclut de la
cible de de déficit public moi j'avais
travaillé il y a longtemps sur cette
fameuse règle d'or consistant à extraire
tout l'investissement public et je
m'étais retrouvé avec tous mes collègues
économistes qui me tombaient à bras à
courci de dessus en disant mais mon
pauvre Jérôme tu as rien compris à
partir du moment où cette règle sera
imposée les gouvernements nous diront
que quoi qu'il fasse c'est de
l'investissement public donc il y aura
plus plus rien qui permettra de de de
limiter la la la l'augmentation de la
dette publique et et depuis 20 ans que
on discute de cette règle on n'a jamais
pris le temps de se poser la question de
savoir queles étai les dépenses
publiques dont collectivement on
souhaitait préserver l'évolution tout en
se disant que pour ce qu'on préserverait
pas ben il faudrait lever des impôts
pour financer ces autres dépenses donc
la la la partition n'est pas entre
dépenses de fonctionnement et dépenses
d'investissement mais entre dépenses
qu'on souhaite préserver pour lesquelles
on est prêt à s'engager sur une
augmentation tion de dett publique parce
qu'on pense que c'est bon pour notre
avenir et les dépenses qu'on souhaite
continuer d'évoquer de financer mais
cette fois-ci par des impôts on peut pas
créer de nouvelles infrastructures
universitaires sans prof s'il y a pas de
prof ça sert à rien on l'a longtemp fait
dans des programmes d'ajustement dans
les pays africains les pays en en
développement on leur donnait de
l'argent pour construire des écoles ils
avaient pas les moyens d'avoir des
instituteurs et des institutrices ça n'a
aucun intérêt donc il faut absolument
réfléchir à une vision microéconomique
de l'évolution des finances publiques
mais là tout reste à faire
malheureusement donc je suis navré de
vous dire que il y a pas de dépenses à
préserver il y a une réflexion à avoir
sur ce qu'on a envie de faire à l'avenir
next generation eu qui a évoqué Luc
tologia à juste titre c'est une façon
d'engager l'Union européenne vers
l'accélération de la transition
numérique et écologique mais il est
évidemment important que cela ne se
fasse pas au détriment d'autres secteurs
que que nous jugerions important
collectivement peut-être la santé
peut-être l'éducation et c'est là que
j'en viens au dernier point qui a été
qui a été évoqué c'est comment est-ce
qu'on
améliore l'évolution et les discussions
de finances publiques je crois qu'il
faut entendre cette pluralité de point
de vue le cadre budgétaire européen
actuel pas celui qui est actuellement
discuté celui que nous avons qui reste
officiel et un cadre désué et qui n'
n'incorpore pas de de pluralité
politique il y a une vision extrêmement
comptable des finances publiques on doit
revenir à 60 on doit revenir à 3 comme
si c'était les bon niveau de dette et de
déficit public alors que personne n'a pu
jamais démontrer qu'ils étaient optimaux
les États-Unis ne les respectent pas et
certains d'entre vous nous ont rappelé
que c'était quand même l'économie
américaine une économie très très très
puissante au plan international donc il
faut sortir du logiciel du du cadre
mastrichien dont Monsieur se foutait
tout tout à l'heure et et pour essayer
de réfléchir collectivement à une
meilleure appropriation politique des
politiques budgétaires et à pas se
laisser dictter les politiques
budgétaires par le gouvernement auprès
du Parlement par par une commission pour
un un pays en particulier et cette
discussion là pour l'instant elle a pas
avancé merci merci Monsieur
écal Merci monsieur le
Président
euh je vais commencer par le la
signification du du rapport de la dette
publique au
PIB vous avez cité d'ailleurs monsieur
le Président en introduction des travaux
de Reinard trogof qui nous disait que
au-delà d'un seuil de 90 % du PIB on
aurait des problèmes moi personnellement
j'ai toujours dit que les économistes
étaient incapables de fixer un tel seuil
parce qu'ils sont totalement incapables
de dire à partir de quel niveau
d'endettement tout d'un coup les
créanciers d'un état se mettent à avoir
peur et exiger des taux d'intérêt de
plus en plus élevés et ce qui peut finir
par aboutir à un défaut de paiement on
voit bien et on on l' on l'a cité il y a
des pays comme le Japon qui ont une
dette publique depuis 10 ans supérieure
à 200 % du PIB on a cité l'exemple
américain en fait il y a des tas de
raisons qui peuvent faire que vous
pouvez vivre très bien avec une dette
publique très élevée des raisons qui
sont parfois très qualitative comme tout
simplement la crédibilité de votre
politique publique si vous êtes une
entreprise ou un particulier vous
expliquez à votre banquier que ça pose
aucun problème de vous endetter parce
que tout tout est sous contrôle vous
avez des perspectives de croissance de
votre de vos revenus qui sont très
bonnes et ben votre banquier va
continuer à vous prêter de l'argent et
pour les états c'est pareil donc il y a
pas de limite et quand on regarde les
pays par exemple que que vous avez cité
il y a derrière il y a des raisons
particulières les États-Unis je pense
que la comparaison avec les États-Unis
n'est pas bonne pour une raison très
simple c'est que l'ensemble du monde a
toujours besoin de dollars aujourd'hui
qu'on le veuille ou non donc tout le
monde prête en dollar aux États-Unis et
quelque part la si les États-Unis
peuvent s'endetter c'est aussi parce que
ils ont 12 porte-avions nucléairees donc
ils ont une puissance économique
militaire et cetera qui font que
personne n'imagine que un jour les
États-Unis feront défaut le Japon c'est
autre chose le le Japon il a une épargne
intérieure très importante qui fait que
non seulement il peut financer l'État
japonais mais il finance aussi le reste
du monde
et ça ça renvoie à une autre question
qui qui a été posée c'est la balance des
paiements courants le Japon a un
excédent de ces paiement courant
traditionnel et donc un en fait est dans
une situation créditrice sur le reste du
monde qui fait donc voilà qu'il est il a
des des créances sur le reste du monde
c'est pas du tout le cas des autres pays
et ça ça peut expliquer c'est en tout
cas c'est une des forces du Japon qui
lui permet de s'endetter la France est
dans une situation inverse nous nous
avons depuis 10 15 ans quasi tous les
ans un déficit de nos paiements courants
ce qui Infiné se traduit par le fait que
nous sommes nous globalement endetté
vis-à-vis du reste du monde moi je pense
que cet endettement d'ailleurs vis-à-vis
du reste du monde est aussi important
que la dette public euh j'en parle moins
parce que j'ai un
voilà je suis plus je travaille plus
souvent sur les finances publiques mais
je suis aussi inquiet par la situation
d'endettement de la France vis-à-vis du
reste du monde par quand on est endetté
comme ça vis vie enfin quand on a un
déficit des paiements courant soit on
s'endettete soit on vend des actifs soit
ce sont des étrangers qui achète des
actifs on on se satisfait on trouve très
bien que la France soit le premier pays
en Europe pour les investissements
étrangers c'est à double face c'est
c'est très bien ça prouve qu'on est
attractif mais d'un autre côté c'est
parce qu'on en a besoin aussi et donc on
a besoin de capitaux étrangers ce qui
est pas forcément une très bonne chose
donc le le l'endettement vis-à-vis de
l'extérieur c'est aussi un problème al
pour revenir à l'endettement public donc
je ne sais pas à partir de quel niveau
d'endettement public il peut y avoir une
crise et donc je me limite finalement à
dire ce que disent en fait les
économistes la seule chose qu'ils sont
capables de dire c'est en fait il faut
garder le contrôle de la dette faut pas
qu'elle faut pas qu'elle augmente la
soutenabilité c'est une dette publique
qu'on arrive à stabiliser quand les
choses vont bien évidemment quand il y a
une crise elle augmente c'est normal
mais après il faut arriver à la
stabiliser ou à la réduire donc je ne
dis je ne dis rien d'autre donc la
stabiliser ça peut être à 60 % du PIB ça
peut être à 100 % du PIB ça peut être à
150 % du PIB mais je pense que la dette
publique française va continuer à
augmenter si comme je le pense en fait
les marchés considèrent que la BCE sera
toujours là pour intervenir ça peut
durer encore longtemps donc je ne sais
pas jusqu'à quand ça ça va continuer
voilà donc mais la seule chose que je
sais c'est que plus elle est élevée plus
on prend de risque voilà plus la dette
publique est élé je sais pas quand le
risque se matérialisera mais plus la
dette public est élevé plus on prend de
risque donc il faut mieux quand même
prendre des mesures pour faire en sorte
de rigueur pour faire en sorte queelle
n'augmente pas trop qu'on arrive au
moins à la contrôler alors est-ce que ça
peut ces mesures de rigueur c'est
l'autre question essentielle que vous
avez posé est-ce que ça peut avoir des
effets négatifs sur la croissance quand
j'étais au ministère des Finances il y a
une trentaine d'années à la direction de
la prévision qui après a été fusionné
avec le trésor j'avais un directeur qui
disait souvent un bon économiste est
kenésien à court terme et classique à
long terme ce qui veut dire qu'en terme
de politique budgétaire je pense que
quand on essaie de réduire le déficit
public oui on a un effet négatif sur
l'activité à court terme oui il y a des
multiplicateur oui il a mon voisin de
droite a raison mais ce sont des effets
de court et moyen terme au bout de 4 5 6
ans et cetera ces effets multiplicateurs
même dans les modèles de l'OFCE il
s'atténuent il ils diminuent et donc au
total oui on a peut-être un petit il
reste peut-être un petit effet négatif
sur l'activité mais ça aura peut-être
permis de prendre moins de risque en
terme de finances publies parce que on
aura réduit le déficit public et repris
le contrôle de la dette publique donc
oui et ça cet effet multiplicateur pour
répondre à une autre question c'est vrai
qu'il dépend de la manière dont vous
réduisez le déficit public c'est vrai
que quand vous jouez sur
l'investissement public c'est là où vous
avez les effets multiplicateurs les plus
importants donc si vous réduisez
l'investissement public vous allez avoir
les effets négatifs les plus importants
si vous augmentez l'investissement
public vous allez avoir les effets
positifs les plus importants si vous
jouez sur les l'impôt sur le revenu ou
l'impôt sur les sociétés ou même les
prestations sociales vous avez des
multiplicateurs beaucoup plus faibles en
fait donc c'est vrai que ça dépend on
peut le montrer assez facilement ça
dépend de la manière la manière dont
vous
procédez est-ce qu'il faut pour autant
je dirais appliquer une règle d'or à la
française je ferai la même même réponse
que Jérôme Créel c'est-à-dire que oui
d'un point de vue macro c'est vrai que
l'investissement public au sens
classique c'est ce qui a les effets
multiplicateurs les plus importants mais
dans une vision de plus long terme est
classique pour moi encore même dans ce
cas-là ces effets ils sont c'est des
effets de court moyen terme à plus long
terme ce qui est probablement plus il
est probablement plus important de
d'augmenter de faire de l'investissement
dans le capital humain c'est-à-dire
d'avoir des dépenses de fonctionnement
de formation et d'éducation beaucoup
plus important que certains
investissements physiques dans le BTP
qui ne servent à rien et qui n'ont aucun
impact sur la croissance à moyen à plus
long terme donc je me méfie de la règle
d'or au sens français pour pour cette
raisonl alors pour pour
revenir aux règles budgétaires
européennes la mission de la commission
était très difficile je pense que ce
elle a fait ce qu'elle pouvait faire de
mieux parce qu'on lui a demandé
évidemment de raisonner à traiter un
changer bon voilà et et et pour ce ce
qui est du volet correctif du PACT de du
pacte def du traité de Maastricht c'està
direire ce qui se passe quand vous avez
notamment un déficit supérieur à 3 % du
PIB c'est très encadré par le traité
donc il y avait pas beaucoup de marche
de manœuvre pour la de marche pour pour
changer quoi que ce soit donc il fallait
raisonner à traiter un changer essayer
d'être pertinent sur le plan économique
essayer de simplifier et puis certains
petits pays ont dit aussi ont fait
valoir que il fallait pas que ça
conduise un dialogue entre la Commission
et les pays considérés donc il fallait
des règles chiffrées parce que il
fallait éviter d'avoir un traitement je
dirais trop à la tête du client et que
un moyen de de de se prémunir contre ce
type de traitement c'est d'avoir des
règles chiffrées avec voilà des
objectifs à peu près clairs c'est la
quadrature du cercle tous ces objectifs
ne serait-ce que l'objectif de
simplification d'un côté et l'objectif
de pertinence économique à mon avis ils
sont très difficilement conciliables
donc la commission M fait une
proposition qui était peut-être on
pourrait peut-être faire on pouvait
peut-être faire autrement mais je pense
qu'elle a étit cont tenu toutes ces
contraintes elle était bonne après elle
a été complexifiée dans le cadre de la
discussion avec les pays membres parce
que notamment certains ont voulu en
rajouter dans les les les règles
numériques permettant de s'assurer que
on nallait pas être traité à la tête du
client et que tout serait bien balisé
clarifié à l'avant
donc on aboutit en effet à quelque chose
qui pour moi est plus compliqué que ce
qu'on avait
avant et qui à mon avis ne sera pas plus
respecté je rappelle que le pacte de le
traité de Maastrich le pacte de
stabilité tout ces règles restri
rigoureuses ou austéritaire elles n'ont
pour beaucoup de pays elles nont jamais
été respecté les pays qui ne les ont pas
respectés n'ont jamais été
sanctionn le système de sanction il est
toujours le même il est prévu dans le
traité c'est des amendes financières ça
un côté un peu paradoxal impliquer des
amendes financières à des pays en
situation de déficit excessif ça marche
pas ça marche pas et ça n'a jamais
marché ça n'a jamais été appliqué ça
veut pas dire pour moi que les règles
budgétaires sont inutiles je pense que
la l'utilité des règles budgétaires il
faut la comprendre dans une logique ce
que les anglosaxons appellent le comply
or explain soit vous les respectez soit
vous vous expliquez soit vous AZ vous
les respectez soit vous expliquez à au
Père au Conseil des Ministres de l'Union
européenne pourquoi vous ne les avez pas
respectés il y a un dialogue il y a un
débat et vos les pays voisins vous dit
bon bah écoutez la prochaine fois
essayez quand même de faire plus
d'efforts et cetera parce que sinon nous
par ailleurs dans d'autres domaines bah
on sera peut-être pas aussi sympathique
avec vos vos prétensions vos demandes
dans d'autres domaines donc ça marche
dans je pense que c'est utile dans dans
cette logique là mais pour pouvoir
débattre et s'expliquer encore faut-il
que ce soit compréhensible et là c'est
là où je suis inquiet avec les règles
budgétaires actuelles que
j'ai je je crains que les le débat
politique sur ces règles il soit très
limité parce que c'est quand même très
compliqué et donc je pense que on n'est
pas prêt à faire de l'austérité
euh en Europe à cause de ces règles
budgétaires euh et pour revenir pour une
dernière question qui a été posée par le
rapporteur général quels étaient les
quels sont pour moi les modèles de pays
les pays virtueux ben j'avoue que je je
je suis attiré par le assez parce qu'on
fait les pays scandinaves dans les
années 90 les pays scandinaves dans les
années 90 avaient un niveau de dépenses
publiques nettement supérieur aux nôtres
des prélèvements obligatoires nettement
supérieurs ils se sont retrouvés dans
une situation de crise de leurs finances
publiques au début des années 90 ils ont
pris le problème à bras le corps les
macroéconomistes diront ils ont été é
aidé par la situation internationale bon
voilà mais ils ont quand même pris le
problème à bras le cor et B il il s'en
trouve très bien aujourd'hui avec des
dépenses publiques qui sont un peu plus
faibles que les nôtres des prélévement
obligatoire un peu plus faible mais pas
beaucoup et une situation des finances
publiques qui n'a rien à voir elle je le
rappelle que le la dette publique de la
Suède c'est pas 60 % du PIB c'est 40 %
du
[Musique]
PIB merci monsieural Monsieur le
Directeur merci monsieur le Président
merci à tous pour vos questions mes
collègues ont déjà couvert un grand
nombre de de points soulevés je voudrais
revenir sur deux points les les leçons
àise de l'expérience de 25 ans de monque
et puis un point d'étape sur les
négociations de ce nouveau cadre
budgétaire dont nous avons parlé
plusieurs d'entre vous ont soulevé le
point des des leçons apprises au fil du
temps je crois qu'en montrant les les
différents graphiques dans cette
présentation je voulais surtout
souligner la l'évolution du contexte et
la diversité des situations nationales
les 25 ans de monnaie unique n'ont pas
été un long fleuve tranquille l'Union
européenne a été confrontée au deux
pires crises économiques qu'elle n'a
jamais connu depuis la Seconde Guerre
mondiale et vous avez mentionné
l'étergonité des
situation jusqu'à la crise financière
mondiale de 2008 il y avait un processus
fort de convergence
entre entre économie de de la zone euro
et plus généralement de l'Union
européenne en allant vers l'UR à la fin
des années 90 et puis dans les premières
années de l'euro ce processus de
convvergence était très fort la crise
financière mondiale a interrompu ce
processus de convergence l'Union
européenne a subi deux récessions dans
une période de 4 ans
l'aggravation au sein de la zone euro à
travers la crise des dettes souveraines
a conduit à une différenciation accrue
des situations et à des situations
extrêmes dont celle de la Grèce qui
évidemment ressort par rapport aux
autres des leçons importantes ont été
tirées de cette crise financière
mondiale et la crise de la zone euro de
nouveaux mécanismes ont été mis en place
le mécanisme pour en de stabilité les
règles ont déjà été revu vous vous
souvenez d'une première série de
flexibilité sous le PACT de stabilité et
de croissance en janvier 2015 un plan
yunker plan d'investissement a été lancé
pour lancer l'investissement privé au
sein de l'Union européenne et j'ai dit
que c'était pas un long flu tranquille
mais il y a eu des bonnes années si vous
vous rappelez les années
2014-29 sur 5 ans en moyenne l'Union
européenne a ACC cru de 2 % ce n'est pas
rien 14 millions d'emplois nets ont été
créés 14 millions d'emplois c'est un
État membre entre la Belgique et les
Pays-Bas c'est une population
significative le taux de chômage a
baissé il avait atteint un record au
début d'année 2013 plus de 12 % il était
à 6 % fin 2019 son niveau le plus bas
depuis le début de l'Euro euh il y a eu
un inétissement du système bancaire les
déficits publics avaient baissé en
moyenne plus de 6%
au pire de la crise en 2011 à moins de 1
% en fin 2019 il y avait 26 pays en
procéure de déficit excessif au pire de
la crise il n'y en avait plus un seul au
milieu d'année 2019 je dis tout ça pour
montrer que lorsque la crise de la covid
a frappé l'Union européenne était dans
une position bien meilleure bien
meilleure que quelques années au
préalable et sans doute bien meilleure
qu'avant la crise financière mondiale
tout ça parce que un certain nombre
d'efforts d'actions ont été mené dans la
deuxème moitié
des années 2010-2020 et heureusement euh
parce que la crise de la covid a été une
récession majeure sans précédent pour
les économistes pour tous les acteurs
pour chacun d'entre nous euh elle a eu
un impact massif sur les niveaux de dett
qui ont à nouveau augmenté là encore les
règles budgétaire européenne n'ont pas
fait obstacle à une réponse budgétaire
majeure les déficits publics se sont
accrus les dettes la dette augmenté les
étatsmembres ont pu jouer leur rôle de
rempart économique et budgétaire face à
la crise et la réponse européenne a été
radicalement différentes rappelez-vous
les les trois étapes de la réponse
européenne au printemps 2020 euh dès le
mois à Bruxelles c'était le 13 mars nous
avions été renvoyés à la maison le 13
mars je sais qu'en France c'était autour
de ces dateslà euh le confinement a
débuté en quelques semaines l'Union
européenne la commission sur proposition
la commission avec l'accord des
États-membres a décidé de flexibiliser
les règles suspension des ajustements
requis sous le PACT flexibilisation des
aides d'État flexibilisation de
instruments budgétaires au titre de la
cohésion euh tout ça a pris de 3
semaines a été décidé à quiis euh début
avril deuxème étape encore en quelques
semaines la mise en place de trois
parfeux financiers
euh le Mécanisme Européen de Stabilité
le MES a été autorisé à activer une
ligne de crédit de plus de 200 milliards
d'euros pour soutenir les États pour des
besoins de santé en terme de de
financement de la santé la Banque
européenne d'investissement a Activ
était une garantie de garantie pour les
PME et la Commission européenne a activé
l'instrument show dont on n pas parlé
ici ch c'est un instrument de d'emprunt
au niveau européen qui a servi à
financer les systèmes de chômage partiel
dans la plupart des états- membres la
France n'a pas fait le choix d'utiliser
cha mais 19 États-membres on ont
bénéficié plus de 100 milliards d'euros
ont été empruntés et et prêtés aux
États-membres pour développer ces ces
systèmes euh 19 États-membres en on
profit en ont bénéficié 30 millions de
travailleurs on ont pu en profiter 2
millions d'entreprises euh ça c'était
encore une fois une leçon tirée de la
précédente crise financière où les
systèmes par exemple de court sbite en
Allemagne avaiit fait leur preuve
maintenir les gens dans l'emploi pour
éviter pour permettre une reprise forte
ce système show est maintenant terminé
mais sur 2 ans a pu a pu mener son effet
ça c'était le deuxième temps de la
réponse les parfeux financiers et puis
dès le mois de mai la Commission
européenne avec des contributions de
tous les étatsmembres proposait son plan
de relance next generation eu 750
milliards d'euros euh pour renforcer euh
la transition verte et et digitale plus
de 220 milliards d'euros ont déjà été
dépensés je mentionnais euh 41 milliards
euh pour la France la France vient de
soumettre sa troème demande de paiement
euh et et avance fortement dans dans la
mise en œuvre donc le contexte a
radicalement changé des leçons é été euh
tirées euh de la des 10 dernières années
et nous sommes dans un contexte
radicalement différent vous mentionnez
la Grèce euh si vous regardez le cas de
la Grèce
la Grèce au pire de la crise covid est
passée à 200 % de dette dans le PIB fin
2025 elle sera redescendu à 150 % Mo- 50
points en 5 ans alors c'est lié à une
très forte reprise économique soutenue
en grande partie par les les fonds
européens près de 30 % du PIB sur 6 ans
si on additionne next generation et les
fonds de cohésion mais aussi grâce aux
réformes qui ont été mené au pire de des
années de crise le taux de chômage
baisse euh et je disais le taux de
croissance plus ou moins 2 % donc voilà
voilà pour le premier point rapidement
sur le sur les les nouvelles règles
merci de toutes les questions les les
interrogations valides mon point
principal c'est de dire les règles ne
sont pas adoptées donc la Commission
avait lancé une consultation une vaste
consultation en en 2020 beaucoup de
questions ont été soulevées y compris
celle d'une éventuelle règle d'or au
niveau européen pour les raisons
évoquées cette approche n'a pas été
retenue non plus au niveau européen rien
n'empêche les États-membres évidemment
d'avoir d'autres systèmes au niveau
national cette consultation s'est
poursuivie un peu retardée par la
pandémie je le disais euh les
États-membres ont trouvé un accord entre
eux au Conseil Ecofin le 20 décembre le
Parlement qui est colégislateur le
Parlement va voter de même que le
conseil sur ce document sur ce en tout
cas un des trois textes législatifes
liés au volet préventif le Parlement a
trouvé sa position la semaine dernière
donc les trilogues sont en cours euh les
négociations se poursuivent euh y
compris sur tous les points que que vous
avez soulevé du point de vue de la
commission qui effectivement avait avait
présenté ces ces idées en avril euh la
Commission prend part à ces trilogues
mais mais ne se prononce pas sur le
détail de des positions des uns des
autres elle va essayer de faciliter un
accord au cours des des prochaines
semaines ce qui est important de de
retenir c'est que nous souhaitons
évoluer vers une approche différenciée
selon les rusques donc les règles seront
les mêmes pour tout le monde mais
l'effort d'ajustement budgétaire serait
calibré en en fonction des risques de
soutenabilité de dette ça ça serait une
évolution très importante deuxième point
important la prise en compte de réformes
et d'investissement aussi pour soutenir
la croissance potentielle permettrait de
prolonger l'effort
d'ajustement troisièmement il faudra
quand même des des gardesfous vous
parliez de complexité et c'est vrai que
beaucoup de clauses de sauvegarde qui
ont été peut-être ajouté dans la
négociation ajoutent des chiffres au
final l'idée est de digérer cette
complexité dans un indicateur unique
celui des dépenses nettes donc en
fonction des calculs qui pourrait être
fait de soutenabilité de la dette en
fonction des différents clauses de
sauvegarde on serait capable de résumer
l'effort d'ajustement qui serait qui
devrait être mené au cours des
prochaines années voilà pour pour la
philosophie de la réforme je
disais ces règles ne sont pas encore
adoptées ce qui veut dire que les règles
actuelles s'appliquent pour l'année 2024
la l'Union européenne a émis des
recommandations en juillet dernier
de même la Commission a fait part de son
avis sur le projet de budget 2024 de la
France en novembre dernier voilà le
cadre pour 2024 pour 2025 il faut
attendre le calendrier de décision sur
les nouvelles règles si les nouvelles
règles sont adoptées rentrent en vigueur
rapidement nous pourrions agir sous ces
règles sinon nous resterions s le cas
des règles actuelles je vous
remercie merci Monsieur directeur Merci
à VOUS
messieur d'avoir répondu favorablement à
notre invitation et d'avoir apporter vos
différs éclairages sur une question
large comme je l'ai dit qui a suscité
évidemment beaucoup de commentaires et
de de question de nos collègues donc
merci encore une fois et et bonne fin de
journée à vous tous merci monsieur le
Président
merci